oh hey there sorry just putting on the last layer that's a little bit of a moisturizer that is the key to looking great this old it's just moisturizer by the way if you're a moisturizer company feel free to reach out anyway welcome to smartliz take some agents in your life 2007 was done with that they let you use it for a while let me just say that it was a good time welcome to smartliz by the way that's the second time in three days I've heard you use the term agency it is a great term I'm glad that somebody smarter in your life has used it clearly
哦，嘿，抱歉，刚涂完最后一层，那是一点保湿霜，那是看起来年轻的秘诀，顺便说一句，这只是保湿霜，如果你是一家保湿霜公司，请随时联系我，不管怎样，欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋秀》带点主导权到你的生活中吧，2007年已经受够了那套，他们让你用了一阵子，我只能说那是段美好的时光，欢迎来到《聪明笨蛋秀》，顺便说一句，这是我三天内第二次听到你用“主导权”这个词，这是一个极好的词，我很高兴你生命中一个更聪明的人用过它，显然
around you and you're like huh sounds intelligent I'll co-op that no I'm not like you I don't need to grab words I've been familiar with this word for a long time I've never heard you use it before I use it all the time here's the other one you weren't there last night oh you are I wasn't there you weren't there either and I use why weren't you there Sean I had a previous business dinner scheduled Sean business dinner a previous dinner business dinner as opposed to this business dinner it wasn't business last night it was personal okay I know what did it hey but what did I do what did I do did you get a little
在你周围，你会觉得：嗯，听起来挺聪明，我要借用这个词。不，我跟你不一样，我不需要抢别人的词汇，我对这个词已经熟悉很久了。我以前从没听你用过。我一直在用啊。还有另一个，你昨晚不在哦，你是，我不在，你也不在，我用了“你为什么不在，肖恩？”我之前预约了一个商务晚宴，肖恩。商务晚宴？之前的晚餐？商务晚宴？相对于这次商务晚宴来说。昨晚不是商务，是私人的，好吧，我知道。怎么了？嘿，但是我都做了什么？我都做了什么？你是不是收到了一点
something you sent cookies or cookies in my absence can I just say this and I want to see him unappreciative don't say it say it three two one go tasteless the cookies yeah wait but I feel like we interrupted you're about say something hurtful to me about your new found try and taste this I used to have I used to have words years ago I used to say to Jason we had phone conversations and I would sit him you can't use these words and then I would send give him I'd write them down on a piece of paper do you remember that back in the old days I sure fucking don't what just in life you can't use words are you searching for
小东西？你送了饼干，在我不在的时候送了饼干。我能说这个吗？我想看看他是不是不懂感激。别说，说出来，三、二、一，走。没味道的饼干，对吧？等等，我觉得我们打断你了，你本来要对我说什么伤人的话，关于你新发现的——试尝一下这个。我以前，我多年前也有过一些词汇。我以前对杰森说，我们有过电话交谈，我会对他说，你不能用这些词，然后我会给他发——我会把它们写在一张纸上。你还记得吗，在过去的日子里？我他妈的一点也不记得了。在生活中，你不能用某些词？你在寻找
the words or listener he's looking at no I was I was just I do not disturb because I noticed that my yeah I'm gonna do that too so so anyway was it an email from the site word of the day no again that's not my issue so so yesterday so but this is this is on topic so we were having and we were talking about something and Jimmy our friend our good friend Jimmy Burroughs was my right yeah last night Jimmy and Deb came and Jason Jason's wife Amanda was there at his daughter and so anyway so I was able to fill the role of you know Amanda's husband very easily very easily yeah she said she said she said
这些词吗，听众朋友？他在看——不，我只是——我开启了勿扰模式，因为我注意到我的——对，我也要那样做。所以——不管怎样，那是一封来自“每日一词”网站的邮件吗？不，这不是我的问题。所以——昨天——但这跟主题有关，我们当时正在讨论某件事，吉米，我们的朋友，好朋友吉米·伯罗斯在我的——对，昨晚吉米和黛布来了，杰森的妻子阿 Amanda 也在，还有他的女儿，所以——总之，我能够非常轻松地扮演好“阿 Amanda 的丈夫”这个角色，非常轻松。对，她说——她说——她说
she said you're going over the boundaries you're doing too much already she said oh but I use the expression I said you know and somebody would they go there and I guess back in the day you know it was du regur to and they were ill what's there what's that yeah what's there like to do a girl like it's the established like to do you know it's the expected you said that last night yeah it's not an unusual term yes it is coming out of your mouth I've never heard of it talking about your girl never heard you say it before you don't you don't really speak like an intelligent guy and I mean that with it with all the respected sounds
她说：“你有点越界了，你做得太多了。”她说：“哦。”但我用了那个表达，我说你知道，当某人去那里时，我想过去的日子里，你知道，那是理所当然的（du régur），它们是——有什么，那是什么？对，有什么像理所当然的（du régur）一样？就像是确立的——就像是应有的。你昨晚说过这个。是的，这不是一个不寻常的词。是的，从你嘴里说出来就是。我从没听过——说到你的女孩，从没听过你以前说过。你真的不怎么像个聪明人，我是说真的，带着所有的尊重——听起来
like listen listen I don't need to cut and paste words okay because I I've read more this week than you have in your life give me a goddamn it's true you do read a lot and that is why it's surprising that you time no no he's he's sneaky smart people are always surprised anyway that but it was surprising to me that that word generated a lot of sideways glances also wait by the way my niece is in town Tracy's daughter Mackenzie yes right now she's staying here okay I sorry so like last night it makes a lot of sense so why you'd follow up with that yeah no but I wanted to get that out because we
就像——听听，听听，我不需要剪切和粘贴词汇，好吧？因为我这周读的书比你一辈子读的还要多。给我个面子——见鬼的。真的，你确实读很多书，正因如此，才会让人惊讶于你有时——不，不，他是个暗中聪明的人，人们总是感到惊讶。不管怎样，但令我惊讶的是，那个词引来了很多侧目。还有，等等，顺便说一句，我侄女在城里，特雷西的女儿麦肯齐，是的，她现在正住在——好吧，抱歉。所以就像昨晚一样，这就说得通了，你为什么会接着说那个。对，不，我想把这个说出来，因为我们
were like where were you last night I had the business dinner and also my niece is here okay but I know what you mean Jason it did look like he was looking up on his computer like here what were the things I was gonna talk oh yeah yes no so Sean's new talking points that we both like oh my niece is so so you had a business dinner on a Sunday night was it fruitful it was great I love those guys Travis and Oli oh by the way by the way it might have been fruitful but I can guarantee you one thing it was not full of fruit what did you wait a minute what would you do with your niece while
当时在想，你昨晚去哪了？我有商务晚宴，还有我侄女在这。好吧，但我懂你的意思，杰森，他看起来确实在电脑上查东西，比如：哦，这里有什么是我要聊的？哦，对了，是的，不，那是肖恩新的谈话要点，我们两个都觉得：哦，我侄女……所以你在周日晚上有一个商务晚宴，有成效吗？太棒了，我喜欢那群家伙，特拉维斯和奥利。哦，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，它可能有成效，但我可以向你保证一件事：它绝对没有“成果（fruit）”！你等一下，你在商务晚宴期间，怎么安置你侄女的？这个——我想说一件事。好吧，你喜欢这个。我的朋友之一是奥利·米克尔森，他刚刚入选了UCLA足球名人堂。哇，那太酷了。是的，太棒了。那非常酷，所以我跟他还有另一个朋友——旅行——我知道他有德里克。你知道我做了什么吗？这是真的，肖恩，支持我，就在过去的三天里，我和肖恩进行了FaceTime，他当时在Koi，我和大卫·斯佩德在一起。和大卫·斯佩德？嗯，他当时在那，但他在那。对，你——那个踢足球的家伙闻起来像冰冷的樟脑油吗？很多足球运动员闻起来都有肌肉放松膏的味道。他们闻起来挺正常的。你在进行你的大买卖时，你侄女在干什么？她来这里参加一个婚礼，然后她试图——我告诉她后门是怎么开的，我们找了一个真正的受人尊敬的客房。我敢打赌她只是个小孩。对，不，但后来她——因为她不知道锁是怎么用的，所以我早上又得打个电话。哦，嘿，等等，对不起，杰森。太棒了，你刚才说什么？你嘴里塞满东西在聊什么？还记得他以前总是数落我吗？看看他现在这样。好吧，我不是在告诉——正在故事中间咬了一口。这太好吃了！虚伪的顶峰。你知道我
you were at this business dinner this this I want to say this one thing well you love this one of my friends is Oli Mickelson who just got inducted into the UCLA Hall of Fame for soccer wow that's pretty cool yeah it's amazing that's very cool and so I had dinner with him and another friend travel I know he did have Derek you know what I did do this is true Sean back me up within the last three days I FaceTime with Sean and he was at Koi I was with David Spade with David Spade well he was there but he was there yeah did you're did the soccer guy smell like icy cold like liniment a lot of soccer players smell like muscle
现在在吃什么吗？不，你猜我在吃什么？一个 Think 棒。你知道我现在在享受什么吗——如果你能用鼻子呼吸的话——我现在享受的是巧克力奶油纸杯蛋糕口味，18克蛋白质，2克糖。哦，天哪，当他们送你几盒时，你又省下了150美元。去哪儿？哪里是世界上最好的——等等，把 Think 棒的标准定得那么高，你个该死的笨蛋！好吧，所以我今天开车去房子时差点迟到，在我崭新的——我只想顺便提一个汽车品牌，你知道，现代。还有任何嘉宾登场前的闲聊吗？你们知道——哦，
relaxing cream they do smell just fine what was your what was your niece doing during your big deals she was here for a wedding and then she tried to I told her how the back door worked and we got a real respect to guest I'll bet she's just a kid yeah no but then she you know cuz she didn't know how the lock works so I gotta call it again in the morning oh hey wait I'm sorry Jason what awesome what did you say what are you talking with his mouthful remember he used to give me shit look at it right now well I wasn't telling it was in the middle of a story taking a bite this is so good height of hypocrisy you know what
我——好吧，他可以滔滔不绝，但你知道吗，我们的嘉宾不应该坐在这里听我们的废话，因为我们有一个好节目，事实上，这将是一个很棒的节目，我们会看到的，我正双手交叉祈祷。你会注意到这样一种表达：你知道，有少数人在他们所做的事上表现卓越，你知道，无论什么领域，总有很多人做得很好，但很少有人能以一种无与伦比的方式在他们的领域中主导一切，无论是在艺术、商业还是其他什么领域。但我认为这次值得做一个小小的开场白，因为对我来说，这个人——几十年如一日——远远超越了以前和以后任何人所做过的。我现在有点紧张，我的手心有点出汗，即使我知道这家伙——每年赢得热食大胃王比赛的人，这跟那个差不多，但要乘以一百，而且他每年都这样做——就像他连续25年每年都这样做一样。如果你告诉8岁、9岁、10岁到40岁的我，我们今天会坐在这里，让这个人上我们的节目，我会叫你
I'm eating right now right no guess what I'm eating a think bar you know what I'm enjoying right now if you could breathe through your nose what I'm enjoying right now is the chocolate and cream cupcake flavor 18 grams a protein two grams of sugar oh man you've saved yourself another 150 bucks when they send you a couple boxes on where to go where the nicest in the world wait is set the think bar high you fucking dummy all right so I was almost late today driving to the house in my new no I just want to mention a car brand real quick you knew Hyundai yeah any any other pre-guest chatter you guys know oh
骗子，因为我会敬畏过度，紧张得连话都说不出来。韦恩·格雷茨基！我一生的挚爱，冰球。哦，天哪，我刚刚叫他什么？我只是叫他——我只是叫他“伟大的那一个（The Great One）”。是韦恩·格雷茨基。我知道你是谁。当我说——我从没叫过他——我完全知道你是谁。对不起，热球大胃王那家伙，我对自己有点失望。我们很久以前在TNT上请过威尔，我说：好吧，我真的很想做你的节目，我真的很想上，我爱你们所有人，我很高兴我能来。威尔的心情爆炸了，完全炸了。更不用说韦恩了，他们把我放在球门网里，他们让我拿着守门员的球棍、手套和阻挡垫，韦恩向我射了几门球，目的是——进一个。你进球了，不用担心，韦恩。我有点生疏了，毕竟61岁了，没有年轻时那么敏捷了。你做得很好。你觉得——你觉得有没有可能——我知道我们对高尔夫有着共同的热情——你觉得你有没有可能在，比方说，高尔夫上达到你在冰球上的一半水平？没门，不可能。两个原因：因为你在冰球上太厉害了……那倒不是，不，但你必须练习，对吧？每天我去球场时，达斯汀都会对我说：我们去练习场吧。我总是说：达斯汀，我就是我，我不会变得更好，我只希望不要变得更糟。但如果你成为一名精英运动员，无论你从事什么运动，这背后都需要大量的艰苦工作和练习。是的，完全是这样，这也是你们所做的，你不能一蹴而就，这需要巨大的承诺，而我对高尔夫没有这种承诺，但我对它有爱，因为它令人享受。是的，是的。肖恩，你知道他在谈论韦恩的女婿达斯汀·约翰逊，他是世界上排名最高的高尔夫球手之一，曾在不同时期排名第一，
I well I go on and on you he could go on and on but you know what our guest doesn't deserve to have to sit here listen to our priest because we got a good show in fact this is gonna be a great one our we will see I'm crossing my fingers and you'll notice the expression that you know there are a few people who excel at what they do you know whatever discipline there are always people who do a lot of you know who do it well but it's rare that you have people who dominate in a way that is like unlike anybody else's dominated in whatever their discipline is in the arts just sometimes want to get a
你知道的，他是一个惊人的大满贯得主等等等等。其实，韦恩，有一次杰森和我撞见你和珍妮在打高尔夫，大概是六个月前吧。还有一次，我们看到达斯汀在我们要打球的地方练习，我把球从球道击飞到了练习区，我穿过树林看到他在那里，我说：嘿，DJ，刚刚击了我的球，从这里没人能看到你，把它放在果岭上，五杆洞。如果你一直待在那里，直到——我只是想听到杰森从球道那边喊：好球！我当时既兴奋又惊讶，你们竟然有足够的胆量走到他面前，因为我现在跟一起打球还是会紧张，我心想：哇，这些家伙真行，真为他们高兴。而且你们走过去的方式——他是个大人物，他只是很有威慑力，但他太好了，你知道，他就是那种对比赛充满热爱的人，如果他跟初学者、十差点球手或跟他的好兄弟们一起打球，他有着圣人般的耐心，他真的热爱这项运动，那是很特别的东西。你要么有这种特质，要么没有，而他有。我觉得他跟我一起打球会感到沮丧，因为我很擅长。但我记得我们有一年在圆石滩打球，他在第二个洞告诉我：用三号木击球。我说：不，让我用九号铁，九号铁打那个长五杆洞，也就是二号洞。果岭周围有这么多人，因为我们跟乔丹·斯皮思和达斯汀·约翰逊一起打球，当时我跟杰克·奥一起，我们四个。我心想：达斯汀，我能做的最糟糕的事就是离洞还有80码，我不能离洞80码。果不其然，我离洞79码，我用沙坑杆打了个剃头球，直接击中了这位可怜的女士——不，我——我不能打了，我有两个洞没法打。我当时想：好吧，这是我最后一年参加这个比赛了，在这么多人面前打球太难了。你把球给她了吗？
business or whatever I do but this one deserves a little bit of a preamble because this to me this person had has for consistently for decades went far and above and far and beyond what anybody had ever done before them and since I'm I'm a little bit nervous right now my palms are a little even though I know this guy that wins the hot dog eating contest every year this is it's the equivalent of that but times a hundred and and he did it every it's like he did it every year for for 25 years if you told 8 9 10 to 25 to 40 year-old me that we'd be sitting here today having this person on our show I'd call you a
对，我把球给了她，我签了一副手套，我给她——我给她买了一杯她想要的饮料，谢天谢地她戴着眼镜，眼镜挡了一下，否则真的会留下印记，球差不多击中了她的眼镜，击中了正确的位置，所以没有想象中那么糟糕。但让我告诉你，在人们面前打球太难了，威尔马上就要体验到了，我们俩都要去——我以前做过，但威尔没有。我们在二月份要打圆石滩。让我告诉你，你的双膝会颤抖，特别是当摄像师跑过来，拿着肩扛摄像机来到你身后，就在球道正中央的时候。但杰森，我们去年打过，当我们打——那是叫什么？捷恩斯。我们在本地打捷恩斯时，那不算太糟，因为人没那么多。没错，你要去打圆石滩，那里会有25,000人，让我告诉你，如果你打出一个烂球，他们会让你知道；如果你打得好，他们也会让你知道。我听到你说达斯汀叫你“先生”了吗？是的，他是个非常尊重的年轻人。那——那——我想让杰森叫我“先生”，那会很棒。好吧，我又没有跟你女儿睡觉。
liar because I would be too in awe and too nervous to even talk about it Wayne Gretzky my great love of my life is hockey oh my god did more I just call it what I just call it it's the great one it's Wayne Gretzky I know who you are when I've never called it I totally know who you are sorry about the hot dog eating guy I was getting disappointed in myself we had will on TNT a long time ago and I said okay I really want to do your show I really want to be on it love all through you guys and I'm glad I'm here exploded wills mine totally my mind well even more so Wayne they put me in net they let me hold the
你懂的。那么，他是个什么子女婿？他是最好的。有没有——高尔夫球界有一句老话，当你打出一个烂球时，你叫它“女婿”，人们问那是什么意思，你说：这跟我脑海中想的有点不太一样。我是相反的，我的女婿是最好的，他对孩子们很好，是个好父亲，这很酷。他只是个了不起的家伙。你知道，几年前我们搬到了佛罗里达，这样就能离两个外孙近一点，我另一个儿子也有一个一岁的小女儿，所以我们开车都在七分钟之内，一切都安排得非常完美。当他去旅行时——他在亚洲，我想他们现在在曼谷，所以两个男孩可以和珍妮跟我住在一起，至少家里还有人。哦，太棒了。是的，所以一切都安排得很好。是的，他是个了不起的家伙。他有没有给你什么建议，能用在你的高尔夫球技上？哦，是的，你知道的，是的，他太不可思议了，如果你跟他一起打球，你会惊叹于他对高尔夫的精通。我总是对人说，他真的是个奇才（savant）。他知道是什么草，有多厚，草下面有多少土壤，果岭往哪个方向走。我总是说：你为什么不找个人帮你读果岭？他说：为什么？我是世界第一，如果我都读不懂，谁能读懂？我说：嗯，有道理。但你知道，他总是帮我。不过我不去练习场，我不练习，但当我们在球场上时，他会给我一些小提示、小秘诀，他对待一起打球的每个人都这样，他太热爱了。杰森，珍妮——韦恩，杰森太嫉妒了，他简直停不下来。我们可以用整整一个小时来问高尔夫的问题。但遗憾的是，我们这里有韦恩·格雷茨基，你知道的，冰球，我们首先要谈谈——韦恩，正如我可能对你说的，但就像你知道的，作为一个多伦多长大的男孩，你知道冰球就是我一生的挚爱，对你也是如此，虽然在很多方面我的关系很不相同，我是一个观察者。但你知道，对我来说，我记得——肖恩你甚至说过，我喜欢你的那种说法，就像“我知道你是谁”，肖恩并不是一个超级体育迷，但他只是觉得：哦，天哪，韦恩·格雷茨基，这让我大开眼界。作为一个孩子，我记得我最早的冰球记忆，如果你是一个加拿大孩子，它是如此丰富，你和冰球之间的那种关系，它对你的意义不仅仅是一场比赛，它是关于你的家庭和诸如此类的事情。所以我有那些记忆：在街尽头的第一块露天冰场上滑冰，无论如何，去看比赛，第一次听到人群的轰鸣声时感到紧张。你谈到了——你谈到了穿上装备，穿装备需要多长时间，完成所有这一切。那种盛况，穿上所有那些东西的仪式感，韦恩，跟我聊聊你关于冰球的第一记忆。我的关系可以追溯到很久以前，我两岁时就开始滑冰了。为什么？怎么回事？我不知道，一个叔叔传给我一双冰鞋，它们有这么大，我父母家现在还留着第一双。我开始在后院滑冰，我祖父母住在农场里，他们有一个叫尼思河（Knith River）的地方，汇入她院子后面的格兰河，冬天河水会结冰，那就是我开始滑冰的地方。你知道，我会在那里待上几个小时又几个小时，两岁、三岁、四岁、五岁，然后进屋。你知道，这感觉是世界上最糟糕的感觉，但也是最好的感觉，当你脱下冰鞋把它们放在取暖器上，因为它们冻得太僵了，当它们开始融化时，疼得更厉害。但你熬过了那种刺痛感停止的阶段，只会想：好吧，我等不及明天了。所以我就像其他所有孩子一样，我正在说这个——我最美好的记忆之一，我记得跟我爸爸开车去我的第一场比赛，无论出于什么原因，我记得它就像昨天发生的一样。我六岁，我尝试加入这支球队，在那个年代，他们有一支10岁的球队，如果你进了那支球队，你就在那里打球，如果你没进，你就没得打。我五岁就进了那支球队。哇。教练对我说：“我们能看看你的出生证明吗？”我爸爸把它交给他，然后说：“他不能打，他年龄不够。”所以我记得哭着开车回家。第二年他们说：“好吧，那就让他打吧。”我在那支球队打了五年。但我这个故事的重点是，我的最后一场比赛——我太幸运了，我总是对运动员说：如果你有机会在纽约打球，没有什么比为游骑兵队、洋基队或尼克斯队效力更伟大、更美好、更棒的了。曼哈顿的球迷有一种非常特别的东西，我得以在麦迪逊广场花园打我的最后一场比赛。那是下午三点的一场比赛，我总是提前大约六个小时去球馆。提前六个小时？哦，是的，因为我可以在下午两点进入更衣室，准备七点半的比赛，没有人能打电话给我，没有人能跟我说话，我会喝杯咖啡，坐在——杰森的梦想，我只是放松一下。你知道，我们那个年代没有手机，所以人们找不到我。所以我最后一场比赛，我说：你知道吗，这就是我要做的。我开车接了我爸爸，我说：你知道吗，你开车送我去我的第一场比赛，我要开车和你一起去我的最后一场比赛。所以我开车载着我爸爸穿过曼哈顿，我们当时住在上东区，到达麦迪逊广场花园。赛后，我的妻子珍妮对我说：跟爸爸的车程怎么样？我说：珍妮，太棒了，但这是我去打冰球这辈子最糟糕的10分钟。她问：为什么？我说：一路上，他一直在拍我的膝盖说：“你知道的，你还能再打一年。”我说：我受够了。我说：你知道吗，爸爸，我真的很感激。所以游骑兵队人太好了，他们给我和珍妮买了一辆新车，他们让我爸爸把车从角落里开出来。当他把车开向中场冰面时，我打开车门让他出来，结果他系着安全带。我对爸爸说：你系着安全带干什么？他说：你永远说不准。他看着车不太对劲，然后他说：这不是他们送我的漂亮车吗？我说：我很遗憾地告诉你，进了一千个球的是我，不是你。告诉他是我的车而不是他的车，这真让我心碎。所以这一切都回到了当孩子的时候，对吧？没有什么能与之相比。太酷了，我们马上回来。
goalie stick and a glove in a blocker and Wayne took a couple shots on me which was to get one through you got a couple through don't worry when was I'm a little rusty little 61 I don't quite have the hands that I used to have when I was young did okay do you think that do you think there's any chance as I know we share a passion for golf any chance you think you could ever get let's say half way as good as you were in hockey in golf not a chance no two reasons because you were so good at hockey that's no no no but you have to practice right and every day when I go to the course Dustin will say to me let's go to the
《聪明笨蛋秀》由 Helix 赞助支持。你为孩子们买什么床垫？你该怎么做？从哪里开始？你不能问你的孩子：“嘿，你的睡眠指数是多少？”“嘿，你该怎么做？”所有这些在孩子面前都没用，因为他们会说：“我不知道床，我只想要睡觉的床。”我的孩子们就是这么说话的。所以 Helix 的团队和我一起搞到了一些 Helix 儿童床垫。让我告诉你，这些小家伙们睡得像小天使一样，真是难以置信。他们非常快地把床垫送到了家里，我们在第一晚就把它们铺在床上。这不是夸张，两个孩子整晚都比平时多睡了一会儿，这是一次非常积极的体验。Helix Sleep 是一个高级床垫品牌，根据你的独特睡眠偏好提供定制床垫。Helix 产品线包括14种独特的床垫，包括一系列豪华型号、适合高大身材睡眠者的床垫，甚至还有我刚才跟你提到的专门为儿童制作的床垫。有什么比去床垫店躺在一张你明知有无数人曾带着满身污垢和衣服躺过、鬼知道他们去过哪里的床垫上更糟糕的事吗？你将能够找到最适合你的床垫。考虑到你花在床上的时间有多少，听起来相当不错，你绝不应该在舒适度上妥协。Helix 还提供具有冷却技术的床垫，可以帮助调节你的体温，无论什么季节。我的意思是，你需要我给你多少理由去买一个能让你睡得更好的超级棒床垫？你需要一百万个理由吗？我不这么认为，朋友，我认为你只需要一个。Helix 为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单最高立减200美元并赠送两个免费枕头的优惠。访问 helixsleep.com/smartless。有了 Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。
ranger and I'm always like Dustin I am what I am yeah I'm not gonna get any better I hope I don't get worse but if you become an elite athlete or whatever sport you're in the hours of hard work and practice that goes into that yeah yeah exactly what you guys do too it you don't just do it overnight it takes a lot of commitment and I don't have that commitment for golf but I have the love for it because it's enjoyable yeah yeah and Sean you know he's talking about Wayne's talking about his son-in-law Dustin Johnson who's one of the top ranked golfers in the world in and out of being number one at various points you
《聪明笨蛋秀》的听众朋友们，我们得到了美国宝石学院（GIA）的支持。希望之钻（Hope Diamond）、偶像之眼（Idol's Eye）、泰勒-伯顿钻石（Taylor Burton）——世界上一些最著名的钻石都由美国宝石学院（GIA）进行过分级。他们是钻石领域的长期权威科学机构，也是钻石“4C”标准的创造者。也许你听说过它们：切工（cut）、净度（clarity）、颜色（color）和克拉（carat）。好吧，你知道希望之钻重达45克拉以上，并且据传是被诅咒的吗？好吧，显然诅咒并不包含在 GIA 的报告中，否则那就是“5C”了，他们曾一度这样做，然后他们觉得：不，这太——这不够科学，所以还是4C。但我告诉你 GIA 报告中列出的更重要的信息是什么，包括钻石是天然的还是实验室培育的。当我在买钻石时，我可想知道这个。GIA 对世界上最珍贵的钻石进行分级，包括你的钻石。GIA 分级的每一颗钻石都附带一份报告，其中包含有关你钻石的信息，包括4C。选择由 GIA 专家分级的钻石，放心购买。在 GIA.edu 了解更多信息。再说一次，那是 GIA.edu。
know and he's just a phenomenal major winner etc etc who we actually Wayne one of the times Jason I ran into you and Janet playing golf I guess about six months ago but one other time we saw Dustin he was practicing where we were playing and I hit my shot off the fairway into the practice area and I came through the trees and I see him there and I said hey DJ just hit my shot nobody can see you from here just put it on the green part five you would have been there until I just wanted to hear Jason from the fairway going what a shot I was I guess thrilled that you guys had enough guts to get in front of
我们得到了 ZipRecruiter 的支持。你知道他们的口号是：“ZipRecruiter，招聘的最聪明方式”。但我觉得应该是：“ZipRecruiter，《聪明笨蛋秀》听众的招聘最聪明方式”。不知道这顺口吗？你在招聘吗？你在招什么类型的角色？也许你需要招一个身兼数职的人——不是真的戴很多帽子，除非那是家帽店。重点是，想要找到一个能胜任多种不同角色的人可能很有挑战性；或者你可能有一个简单的岗位要填补，但找一个真正适合你公司的人却花了很长时间。无论你需要在纽约招聘一名土木工程师、在内布拉斯加州招聘一名儿科护士、在科罗拉多州招聘一名律师，甚至是在密苏里州招聘一名吉祥物，ZipRecruiter 都能帮你快速找到合格的候选人。现在你可以在 ziprecruiter.com/smartless 上免费试用。从会计师到动物学家以及介于两者之间的所有职业，ZipRecruiter 的匹配技术能够找到具备适合你工作的经验的人，并将他们推荐给你，然后你可以邀请你的首选候选人申请。听起来多么文明！它是如此高效，以至于在 ZipRecruiter 上发布职位的雇主中，有五分之四的人在第一天内就找到了优质候选人。现在就在这个专属网址免费试用：ziprecruiter.com/smartless。再次重复：ziprecruiter.com/SMARTLESS。ziprecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，招聘的最聪明方式。
him because I still get nervous playing with him and I'm like wow these guys all right good for them and the way you guys went he's a big deal he's just intimidating but he's so nice you know he's one of those guys he just has a love for the game and if he plays with a beginner or a tan handicap or with his boys he has the patience of a saint he just truly loves the game and that's something really special you either have that or you don't and he has that he gets frustrated I think playing with me because I'm very good but I remember we played at Pebble one year and he told me on the second hole he said hit your
现在回到节目中。你的父母是如何应对你的名气的？这可能给了他们巨大的自豪感，但我打赌对于他们在家乡的生活来说，这挺美好，但我敢打赌也有一些时刻这带来了真正的干扰。这不仅是你生活中的巨大改变，对他们来说也是巨大的改变。那是他们一直都能适应的事情，还是说他们为此感到了困扰？是的，我爸爸一直非常适应。他热爱冰球，他喜欢谈论冰球，喜欢和人们、孩子们在一起。他一直为男孩和女孩举办冰球锦标赛，直到他去世的那一天，直到现在，在圣诞节期间，他们仍然在举办这个比赛。太棒了。这是全加拿大最棒的锦标赛之一。这很艰难，你知道，我14岁时就离家居住了。人们总是说：“哦，你离家去打冰球了。”其实我并没有。我住在那个小镇上，有那么多的媒体关注，那么多的炒作。我们有一天聚在一起，说：“你知道吗，也许去一个更大的城市生活吧。”我搬去和一个素未谋面的家庭同住。我在开学前一天开车去那里，我当时要上九年级，我遇到了那些人，他们成了我第二个父母。我和他们一起住了两年。那是多伦多吗，韦恩？是的，我搬到了怡陶碧谷（Etobicoke），我去了西汉堡中学（West Humber Collegiate），如果你熟悉多伦多的话，它就在多伦多的机场附近。很有趣，因为我上了高中，我在高中的朋友里没有人知道我打冰球。我整年都保密，学校里没有任何孩子——我没有谈论过它，没有人真正知道我是谁。直到今天，学校里的一个孩子，我和他仍然是最好的朋友。每次我去加拿大、去多伦多，我和他都会一起吃晚饭，而他一生中从未打过一场冰球。我总是对他说：“我简直不敢相信你是唯一一个我见过的没打过冰球的加拿大人，而我们却是最好的朋友。”所以我住在那里两年。你住在那里的原因是因为那里有更好的冰球项目供你参与，仅仅是——不，我去那里是为了摆脱聚光灯，做一个普通的日常孩子，像其他人一样去上学，而不是整天接受采访，也不是被单独挑出来。你知道，这很有趣，虽然所有这些关注带来了很多好处，但也产生了一些嫉妒和负面情绪，这对一个13、14岁的孩子来说是不公平的，我的父母也意识到了这一点，这也是我后来搬到多伦多居住的原因。
three with sir and I go no let me hit nine iron nine iron that long par five yeah number two and there's all these people around the green because we're playing with Jordan Spieth and Dustin Johnson and I was playing with Jake Oh and the four of us and I'm like Dustin the worst thing I can do is be 80 yards out I can't be 80 yards out and sure enough I was 79 yards out and I scald a sandwich and I hit this poor lady right here no I couldn't I couldn't play for I couldn't play for two holes and I was like okay this is my last year I'm gonna play in this event it's too hard playing in front of people did you give her the
韦恩不会告诉你的是，因为他很谦虚，你知道他来自一个叫安大略省布兰特福德（Brantford）的小镇，我很熟悉，因为我的表亲们在那里长大。我曾经告诉过韦恩，我叔叔以前在布兰特福德开过一家书店，所以我经常去那里。当我还是个小孩子的时候，安大略省布兰特福德那里总是写着“亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔的故居”。现在当然变成了“韦恩·格雷茨基的故居”了，大家完全不在乎发明电话的那家伙了。你知道，我的演艺生涯非常短暂，洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）曾邀请我主持《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live），我说：“没门，我不演，我不会演戏，我要飞去肯塔基德比赛。”当时我正在看报纸，上面写着“韦恩·格雷茨基将主持《周六夜现场》”。我记得我把报纸拉下来，看着我妻子说：“真的吗？”她说：“总有一天你会为此感谢我的。”所以我就这样来到了纽约。但重点是——而且我太幸运了，迈克·迈尔斯和达娜·卡维太棒了，他们直接带飞了我，还有乔恩·拉维茨。但我这个故事的重点是，从布兰特福德走出的最著名的人物之一就是菲尔·哈特曼（Phil Hartman），我在《周六夜现场》的那周认识了他。他是个天才，是个好人。他总是对我说：“你知道吗，我也来自布兰特福德。”我说：“我知道，菲尔，我太喜欢了。”
ball yeah I give her the ball I signed a glove I got her I got her a drink she wanted and thankfully she had glasses on it kind of stopped at her really would have left a mark and kind of hit her glasses and kind of hit her the right spot so it wasn't as bad as it could have been yeah but let me tell you something it's so hard playing in front of people I wills about to experience that we're both we're gonna I've done it before but Willie hasn't we're doing the pebble in February let me tell you something you're your knees will be shaken especially when the cameraman runs up and gets behind you in the middle
嘿，当你——嘿，韦恩，当你还是个孩子的时候，当你和那个你不认识的家庭住在一起时——我想知道所有那些尴尬的细节。我很多年前做过肯·罗杰斯（Kenny Rogers）的圣诞巡演，谢谢。没有人——那是种让人沮丧的感觉，我以后再讲。而且在巡演期间，有些地方我们必须寄宿——我讨厌他们把我们分开，我们必须跟那些家庭住在一起。太尴尬了，就像：“哦，你好，你睡在别人的床上，你在那里吃饭，你根本不认识他们。”我的意思是，这难道不奇怪吗？一开始非常奇怪。第一个月，我每天晚上都哭着入睡。当然，我父母几乎负担不起打电话给我的费用。我爸爸在贝尔电话公司（Bell Telephone）工作，我知道每天下午4:30，他在贝尔电话公司的一个朋友会给他一条免费线路，他可以打电话给我，看我过得怎么样。我总是会在下午4:30鼓起勇气说：“我过得很好，我很喜欢，没问题，我正在习惯这个。”我当时14岁。所以，有趣的部分是，我们变得非常亲密，直到他们俩去世的那天，他们就像是——
of the fairway with his with his shoulder camera but Jason we did it last year when we played the when we played what was that Genesis yeah we played the Genesis out here that was not bad because there's not as many people that's right you're gonna play pebble there's gonna be 25,000 people there and let me tell you if you hit a bad shot they let you know about it you hit a good shot they let you know about it did I hear you say that Dustin calls you sir yeah he's a very respectful young man does that does that I want Jason to call me sir that would be great well I'm not sleeping with your daughter you
球道上的随身肩扛摄像机拍他。不过Jason，我们去年打那场的时候，打那个……是什么来着？Genesis？对，我们在那打过Genesis，那次还不错，因为人没那么多。没错，你要是去打Pebble Beach，那儿得有25000人，我跟你说，你要是打砸了一个球，他们会让你知道的，打得好他们也会让你知道。我刚才听你说Dustin叫你“岳父”？对，他是个非常尊老爱幼的年轻人。我……我真想让Jason叫我岳父，那太棒了。呃，我可没跟你女儿睡觉，你
know now what kind of son-in-law is he he's the best is he there's there's a old saying in golf when you hit a bad shot you call it a son-in-law and people say what does that mean you say it's not quite what I had in mind I'm the opposite my son-in-law is the best he's great to his kids he's a good father that's cool he's just he's a wonderful guy and you know we moved down here a couple years ago to Florida so we could be by the two grand boys and my other son he has a little daughter who's one-year-old little girl so we're all within seven minutes driving together it's worked out really nicely when he
知道。现在，他是什么样的女婿？他是最棒的。是吗？高尔夫球界有句老话，当你打出一个烂球时，你管它叫“女婿”，别人问这是什么意思，你就说“这不太符合我的预期”。我恰恰相反，我的女婿是最棒的，他对孩子们很好，是个好父亲。太酷了。他就是个绝妙的小伙子。你知道，我们几年前搬到佛罗里达州，就是为了离两个小外孙近一点。我另一个儿子有个一岁的小女儿，所以我们开车七分钟内都能聚在一起，这结果真的很完美。当他
travels there in Asia right now I think they're in Bangkok so the kids the two boys are able to stay with Janet and I so at least somebody's here oh that's great yeah so it's worked out really nicely yeah he's a wonderful guy has he given you any tips that you can use in your golf game oh yeah you know yeah he's incredible because if he played with you you'd be amazed at how much he's a golf savant I tell people this all the time he's truly a savant he knows what kind of grass it is how thick it is how much soil is underneath the grass which way the greens are breaking I always say don't why don't you have somebody help
去亚洲旅行时——现在我想他们正在曼谷——两个男孩就能待在珍妮和我这儿，所以至少还有人在。哦，太棒了。对，所以一切都进行得很顺利。是的，他是个绝妙的小伙子。他有没有给你什么能用在打高尔夫上的秘诀？哦，有啊，你知道的。他简直神了，如果你跟他一起打过球，你就会惊讶于他简直是个高尔夫天才。我总是跟别人这么说，他真的个天才。他知道那是什么草、有多厚、草皮下面有多少土壤、果岭是往哪个方向斜的。我总说，你为什么不找个人帮你
you read greens he goes why I'm number one in the world if I can't read him who can and I said well good point yeah but you know he helps me all the time I don't go up to the range though I don't practice but when we're on the course he'll give me little pointers little tidbits but he does to everybody's playing with he loves it Jason so Jane Wayne Jason so jealous he's just he won't stop at we could fill the whole hour with golf questions yeah but sadly we've got Wayne Gretzky here who you know hockey we want to talk first of all Wayne as I probably told you but like as you know and as a boy from Toronto you know
看果岭呢？他说：“为什么？我是世界第一，如果我都看不准，还有谁能看准？”我说：“好吧，有道理。”不过你知道的，他总是帮我。虽然我不去练习场，平时也不练球，但在球场上时，他会给我一些小建议、小诀窍。而且他对跟他一起打球的所有人都这样，他太热爱了。Jason，看Jason嫉妒得，他简直停不下来。我们本来可以用整整一个小时聊高尔夫问题的，但遗憾的是，我们今天请到了韦恩·格雷茨基。你知道的，关于冰球……首先，韦恩，正如我可能对你说过的，但正如你所知，作为一个多伦多长大的男孩，你知道
hockey is just the love of my life like it is for you in it in a much my relationship with as much different I'm an observer yeah but you know for me I can remember I mean Sean you even said I love the way you said like I know who you are like Sean is not a huge sports fan but he's just like oh my god Wayne Gretzky yeah this is blowing my mind I can as a kid I can remember my first my first earliest memories of hockey and if you're a Canadian kid it's so rich a like that relationship between you and hockey what it means to you is is more than just the game it's about your family and all that kind of stuff so I
冰球就是我一生的挚爱，对你来说也是如此，不过方式很不相同。我跟它的关系没那么深，我只是个旁观者。但你知道的，对我来说，我记得——肖恩，你甚至说过，我喜欢你的说法——我知道你是谁。肖恩并不是个超级体育迷，但他当时反应就是：“哦天哪，韦恩·格雷茨基！这太震撼我的世界了。”作为一个孩子，我还记得我最早关于冰球的记忆。如果你是个加拿大孩子，这种感情太深厚了。你和冰球之间的这种关系、它对你的意义，不仅仅是一场比赛，它还关乎你的家庭诸如此类的事情。所以我有
I have those memories playing the first outdoor rink at the end of my street whatever going to games being nervous with the first time hearing the roar of the crowd and you talked about what you talked about like getting the gear on and how long it takes to get the gear I get to get all of that stuff that the pageantry of right of the ritual of putting all that stuff on talks me a little bit Wayne about your first memory of your relationship with hockey my relationship goes way back I started skating when I was two years old why how come I don't know an uncle passed me down a pair of skates they were both
这些记忆：在街尽头的第一块露天冰场滑冰，不管怎样，去现场看比赛，第一次听到看台山呼海啸般的呐喊时感到紧张。你谈到了……你谈到了穿上装备，以及穿装备需要花多长时间，做所有这些事情，那份庄严感，也就是把所有这些装备穿在身上的仪式感。韦恩，能跟我讲讲你对冰球最初的记忆吗？我和冰球的渊源可以追溯到很久以前。我两岁就开始滑冰了。为什么？怎么开始的？我也不知道。一个叔叔传给我一双溜冰鞋，它们俩
this big I still have them they're my parents house really first pair and I started skating on the backyard of my my grandparents lived on a farm and they had a it's called the Knith River which runs into the Grand River behind her yard and we freeze in the wintertime that's where I started skating and you know I'd be out there for hours and hours two three four five years old come in and you know this will it's the worst feeling but the best feeling in the world when you take your skates off and you put them over a heater because they're so frozen and when they start down thaw they hurt even more but you
这么大。我到现在还留着，在我父母家里呢，那是第一双。我开始在祖父母家的后院滑冰，他们住在农场里，后院后面有一条叫尼思河（Knith River）的河流，它汇入格兰德河（Grand River）。冬天河水会结冰，那就是我开始滑冰的地方。你知道的，我会在那里待上好几个小时，两岁、三岁、四岁、五岁。回到屋里时——你知道，这感觉最糟糕，但也是世界上最棒的感觉——当你脱下冰鞋，把它们放在加热器上，因为它们冻得太僵了，当它们开始解冻时，甚至会更疼，但你
get past that stage where it stops tingling and you just think okay I can't wait for tomorrow so I was like every other kid and I was saying this one of my fondest memories I remember driving to my very first game with my dad I can remember it for whatever reason like it was yesterday I was six years old I tried out for this team and in those days they had a 10 year old team that's if you made that team that's where you played if you didn't make it you didn't play and I made the team as a five year old wow and the coach said to me can we have your birth certificate my dad gave it to me said well he can't
挺过了那种刺痛感，心里只会想：“好吧，我迫不及待想迎来了明天。”所以我就像其他孩子一样。我当时正在说这其中最美好的回忆之一：我记得和爸爸一起开车去打第一场比赛。无论出于什么原因，我都记得清清楚楚，就像发生在昨天一样。我当时六岁，我试训了一支球队。在那个年代，他们有一支十岁年龄段的球队，如果你入选了那支球队，你就在那儿打球；如果没有入选，你就没球打。而我以五岁的年龄入选了那支球队。哇。教练对我说：“我们能看看你的出生证明吗？”我爸爸拿给他看，教练说：“噢，他不能
play he's not he's not of age so I remember driving home crying so the next year they said okay well let him play and I played on that team for five years but the point of my story was my very last game I was so lucky and I always say this to athletes if you can ever play in New York there's nothing greater nothing nicer nothing better than playing for the Rangers or the Yankees or the Knicks there's something so special about the fans in Manhattan and I got to play my last game at Madison Square Garden and it was a three o'clock game and I always went to the arena like six hours before the game six hours oh yeah
打，他还没到年龄。”所以，我记得当时是一路哭着回家的。第二年，他们说：“好吧，让他打吧。”于是我在那支球队打了五年。我这个故事的重点是，我的最后一场比赛……我太幸运了，我总是对运动员们说：如果你有机会能在纽约打球，没有什么比为游骑兵队（Rangers）、洋基队（Yankees）或尼克斯队（Knicks）效力更伟大、更美好、更棒的事了。曼哈顿的球迷有一种非常特别的魅力。我有幸在麦迪逊广场花园（Madison Square Garden）打了我的最后一场比赛。那是一场下午三点的比赛，我总是会在比赛前大约六个小时就去球场，提前六个小时！哦，是的，
because I could get in the locker room at two o'clock for a 730 game nobody could call me nobody could talk to me I'd have a coffee I'd sit in the Jason's dream yeah and I just relaxed you know we didn't have cell phones in those days so people couldn't get a hold of me so my very last game I said you know what this is what I'm gonna do and I drove my dad I said you know what you drove me to my first game I'm gonna drive with you to my last game so I drove with my dad through Manhattan we were living on the Upper East Side got down the Madison Square Garden after the game Janet my wife says to me how was the
因为我可以在两点钟就进入更衣室，去准备一场七点半的比赛。那时没有人能叫我，没有人能跟我说话。我可以喝杯咖啡，坐在那里——Jason的梦想啊！——然后放松一下。你知道，我们那个年代没有手机，所以人们找不到我。所以在我的最后一场比赛，我说：“你知道吗？这就是我要做的。”我开车带我爸去，我说：“你知道吗，你开车带我去打了第一场比赛，我要开车带你去看我的最后一场比赛。”于是我开车载着我爸穿过曼哈顿，我们当时住在上东区，开到了麦迪逊广场花园。比赛结束后，我妻子珍妮对我说：“跟
ride with your dad I said Janet it was great but it was the worst 10 minutes of my life going to a hockey game and she said why is that and I said the whole way there all he kept doing was taffing me on the knee saying you know you can play one more year I said I'm done I said you know what dad I really appreciate it and so the Rangers were so nice they they bought myself and Janet a new car and they had my dad drive out on the car from the corner and as he drives in on the car to center ice I opened the car door to get him out and he's got his seatbelt on and I said to my dad what are you doing with the seatbelt on he
你爸一起开车感觉怎么样？”我说：“珍妮，这感觉太棒了，但这也是我人生中去冰球场最难熬的十分钟。”她问：“为什么这么说？”我说：“整路上他一直在拍我的膝盖，说：‘你知道的，你还能再打一年。’我说：‘我结束了。’我说：‘爸，我真的很感激。’于是游骑兵队太好了，他们给我和珍妮买了一辆新车，并让我爸把车从角落里开出来。当他把车开到冰球场中央时，我打开车门让他出来，结果他系着安全带。我对爸爸说：‘爸，你系着安全带干嘛？’他
goes you just never know he doesn't look good the car and he says he says to me isn't this a beautiful car they're giving me and I said I hate to tell you but I got the thousand goals not you broke my heart to tell him it's my car not his so it all goes back to being a kid right there's nothing like it that's so cool and we will be right back smart list is supported by helix what do you get for your kids mattresses what do you do where do you start you can't ask your kid hey what sleep number are you hey what do you do all that kind of stuff out the window with kids cuz
说：‘你永远不知道会发生什么。’他下车看着那辆车，对我说：‘这不是一辆漂亮的送给我的车吗？’我说：‘我很抱歉地告诉你，那一千个进球是我的，不是你的。’这深深伤了他的心，得告诉他这是我的车而不是他的。所以这一切都回溯到了小时候，对吧？没有什么能比得上它。太酷了。我们马上回来。SmartLess由Helix赞助。你给孩子们买什么床垫？你怎么选？从哪开始？你不能问孩子：“嘿，你喜欢几号硬度的床垫？”嘿，你觉得……所有这些常规手段在孩子身上全都没用，因为
they're like I don't know bed I'm me just want sleep bed that's how my kids talk so the gang at helix worked with me to get some helix kids mattresses let me tell you something these kids they are sleeping like little angels it's unbelievable they delivered really quickly to the house and we put them in the bed first night this is not an exaggeration both kids through the night slept a little bit longer than they normally do it was a very positive experience helix sleep is a premium mattress brand that provides tailored mattresses based on your unique sleep preferences the helix lineup includes
他们会说：“不知道，床嘛，我只想睡觉。”我孩子就是这么说话的。所以Helix的小伙伴们帮我弄了一些Helix儿童床垫。我跟你说，这些孩子们现在睡得就像小天使一样，简直不可思议。他们很快就把床垫送到了家里，我们在当晚就把床垫铺在了床上。这不是夸张，两个孩子当晚都比平时稍微多睡了一会儿，这是一次非常积极的体验。Helix Sleep是一个高端床垫品牌，根据你独特的睡眠偏好提供定制床垫。Helix的产品线包括
14 unique mattresses including a collection of luxury models a mattress for big and tall sleepers and even a mattress made just for kids that I was just talking to you about is there anything worse than going to a mattress store and laying down on a mattress that you know that a bunch of people before you have laid their filthy bodies down on with their clothes who knows where they've been you're gonna be able to find a mattress that works best for you that sounds pretty good considering how much time you spend in your bed you should never have to compromise on comfort helix has mattresses with
14种独特床垫，包括豪华系列、为高个子和体重较重的人设计的床垫，甚至还有我刚才跟你提到的专门为儿童制作的床垫。还有什么比去床垫店躺在一张不知有多少陌生人曾用他们穿着衣服的肮脏身体躺过的床垫上更糟糕的事吗？你将能够找到最适合你的床垫。考虑到你在床上花的时间有多长，这听起来相当不错，你永远不该在舒适度上妥协。Helix的床垫还拥有
cooling technology also that help regulate your body temperature whatever the season I mean this is how many reasons do you need me to give you to get a fantastic mattress that's just gonna give you a better sleep do you need a million reasons I don't think so friend I think you just need one helix is offering up to $200 off all mattress orders and two free pillows for our listener go to helix sleep comm slash martless with helix better sleep starts now smart list listener we are supported by the gemological Institute of America the hope diamond the idols eye the Taylor Burton some of the most
冷却技术，无论什么季节都能帮你调节体温。我的意思是，我需要给你多少个理由来买一张能给你带来更好睡眠的超级棒的床垫？你需要一百万个理由吗？我觉得不需要，朋友，我觉得你只需要一个。Helix为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单最高减免200美元以及两个免费枕头的优惠。访问helixsleep.com/smartless。有了Helix，更好的睡眠从现在开始。SmartLess的听众们，我们得到了美国宝石学院（Gemological Institute of America）的支持。希望之星钻石（Hope Diamond）、偶像之眼（Idol's Eye）、泰勒·伯顿钻石（Taylor Burton）——世界上一些最
famous diamonds in the world have been graded by the gemological Institute of America GIA they are a long-standing scientific authority on diamonds and creators of the diamond four C's maybe you've heard of them cut clarity color and carrot okay so did you know that the hope diamond weighs over 45 carats and is rumored to be cursed okay obviously the curses are not included in the GIA reports that they otherwise that would be the five C's which they had for a while and they were like no it's this is just too it's not scientific enough so it's the four C's but I tell you what is listed with the GIA reports more
著名的钻石都由美国宝石学院（GIA）进行过分级。他们是钻石领域历史悠久的科学权威，也是钻石“4C标准”的创造者。也许你听说过它们：切工（Cut）、净度（Clarity）、颜色（Color）和克拉（Carat）。好，你知道希望之星钻石重达45克拉以上，并且据传是被诅咒的吗？当然，GIA报告里可不包含这些诅咒，否则那就成了“5C”了。他们曾经有过一段时间这么想，但后来觉得：“不，这太……这不够科学。”所以最终还是4C。但我告诉你，GIA报告里列出了什么——更
important information including whether the diamond is natural or lab-grown I would want to know that when I'm getting a diamond GIA grades the most precious diamonds in the world including yours each diamond graded by GIA comes with a report with information about your diamond including the four C's buy with confidence by choosing a diamond graded by the experts at GIA find out more at GIA.edu one more time that's GIA.edu we get support from Zipper Kruder you know their slogan is Zipper Kruder the smartest way to hire but I think it should be Zipper Kruder the smart listless way to hire can't tell if
重要的信息，包括这颗钻石是天然的还是实验室培育的。当我在挑选钻石时，我可太想知道了。GIA对世界上最珍贵的钻石进行分级，包括你的钻石。GIA分级的每一颗钻石都附有一份报告，包含有关你钻石的信息，包括4C标准。选择由GIA专家分级的钻石，放心购买。在GIA.edu了解更多信息。再说一次，网址是GIA.edu。我们得到了ZipRecruiter的支持。你知道他们的标语是“ZipRecruiter：最聪明的招聘方式”吗？但我认为它应该是“ZipRecruiter：SmartLess听众的招聘方式”。不知道
that's catchy are you hiring what type of role you're hiring for maybe you need to hire someone to wear many hats not actual hats unless it's a hat store point is trying to get somebody who can fill many different roles that can be challenging or you might have a simple position to fill but it's taking forever to find someone who's a great fit for your company whether you need to hire a civil engineer in New York or a pediatric nurse in Nebraska or an attorney in Colorado or even a mascot in Missouri Zipper Kruder can help you find qualified candidates fast and now you can try it for free at ziprecruder.com
这顺不顺口？你在招人吗？你在招什么职位的员工？也许你需要招一个能身兼多职的人——当然不是戴很多顶帽子，除非那是家帽子店。重点是，想要找到一个能胜任多种不同角色的人可能很有挑战性，或者你可能只有一个简单的岗位要填补，但要找到一个真正适合你公司的人却花了很长时间。无论你需要在纽约招聘土木工程师、在内布拉斯加州招聘儿科护士、在科罗拉多州招聘律师，甚至是密苏里州的吉祥物，ZipRecruiter都能帮你快速找到合格的候选人。现在你可以在
slash smart list from accountant to zoologist and everything in between Zipper Kruder's matching technology finds people with the right experience for your job and presents them to you and then you can invite your top choices to apply sounds so civilized it's so effective that four out of five employers who post on Zipper Kruder get a quality candidate within the first day try it now for free at this exclusive web address ziprecruder.com slash smart list once again that's ziprecruder.com slash sm a RTL ESS ziprecruder.com slash smart list zip recruiter the smartest way to hire and now back to the show how did
ziprecruiter.com/smartless上免费试用。从会计到动物学家以及介于两者之间的所有职业，ZipRecruiter的匹配技术都能为你找到具备正确工作经验的人才，并把他们推荐给你。然后你可以邀请你首选的候选人来申请。听起来太文明了！它非常高效，在ZipRecruiter上发布招聘信息的雇主中，有五分之四的人在第一天之内就能获得优质候选人。现在就在这个专属网址免费试用：ziprecruiter.com/smartless。再次重申，网址是：ziprecruiter.com/sm-a-r-t-l-e-s-s，ziprecruiter.com/smartless。ZipRecruiter，最聪明的招聘方式。现在回到节目中。你的
your folks handle the the the fame obviously of you that would probably gave them a great sort of pride but I bet for them to back home it was it was it was nice but I bet there were moments where it was really disruptive it was it was a huge change in your life but an enormous change in their life as well was that something that they that they were comfortable with consistently or did they have trouble with that yeah my dad was always very comfortable with it he loved hockey and he loved talking hockey love being around people kids he had him kids hockey tournament for boys and girls till the day he passed and
父母是怎么应对你带来的名气的？显然这会带给他们极大的骄傲，但我敢打赌，对他们在家乡的生活来说……这虽然不错，但我打赌肯定也有让他们觉得很困扰的时刻。这对你的生活是个巨大的改变，对他们的生活也是个巨大的改变。他们一直都能很舒适地面对这一切吗？还是说这给他们带来了麻烦？对，我爸爸一直非常适应。他热爱冰球，热爱谈论冰球，喜欢和人们、孩子们在一起。他一直为男孩女孩们举办青少年冰球锦标赛，直到他去世的那一天，
they still have it going on to this day over Christmas time that's great it's one of the great tournaments in all of Canada it was difficult you know at 14 years old I moved away from home and people always said oh you moved away from home to go play hockey and I really didn't I lived in this small town and there's so much media attention there was so much hype we just kind of got together one day and said you know what maybe go live in a bigger city I moved in with a family had never met before I drove down there the day before school started I was starting grade nine and I met the people and it became like
直到今天，圣诞节期间他们仍然在举办这个比赛。太棒了。这是全加拿大最伟大的锦标赛之一。这确实很难。你知道，我14岁时就离家居住了。人们总是说：“哦，你离家是为了去打冰球。”其实我真的不是因为这个。我住在那个小镇上，有那么多的媒体关注，有那么多的炒作，我们有一天聚在一起，说：“你知道吗，也许我该去大城市住。”我跟一个素未谋面的家庭住在一起。开学前一天我开车去了那里，我要上九年级，我见到了那些人，他们成了就像
second parents to me I lived with them for two years was that in Toronto Wayne yeah I went I moved to Tobaco I went to West Humber Collegiate which is by the airport in Toronto if you're familiar with Toronto and it was interesting because I went to high school none of my friends in high school knew I played hockey I kept it quiet the whole year nobody none of the kids at school I I didn't talk about it nobody really knew who I was to this day one of the kids in that school him and I are still best friends and every time I go to Canada go to Toronto him and I have dinner together and he never played a game of
我第二对父母一样的人。我在他们家里住了两年。那是多伦多的地方吗，韦恩？对，我搬到了怡陶碧宝（Etobicoke），我上了西亨伯中学（West Humber Collegiate），如果你熟悉多伦多的话，它就在机场附近。这很有趣，因为我上了高中后，我学校里的朋友没有人知道我打冰球。我一整年都保持低调，学校里没有任何孩子……我从不谈论它，没有人真正知道我是谁。直到今天，学校里的一个孩子和我依然是最好的朋友。每次我去加拿大、去多伦多，我和他都会一起吃晚饭，而他这辈子从来没打过一场
hockey in his life and I always said to him I said I can't be the only Canadian I've ever met this never played hockey and we're best friends so I lived there for two years and you lived there because it was a better program for you to be involved in as a hunter player just kind of no I kind of went there to be get out of the limelight to be a normal everyday kid to go to school like everyone else and not be doing interviews and not being centered out you know it was interesting because with all the good that came with all that attention there were some jealousies and some negative that was unfair to a 13-14 year old
冰球。我总是对他说：“我不敢相信你是我遇过的唯一一个没打过冰球的加拿大人，而我们俩竟然是最好的朋友。”我在那里住了两年。你住在那儿是因为那里有更好的项目，能让你作为一个冰球运动员更好地发展，还是说只是因为……不，我去那里是为了远离聚光灯，做一个普通的日常孩子，像其他人一样去上学，而不是整天做采访、被当成焦点。你知道，这很有趣，虽然所有的关注都带来了好处，但也有一些嫉妒和负面情绪，对一个13、14岁的孩子来说是不公平的，
which my parents thought yeah and that's consequently why I moved to Toronto well Wayne won't tell you is because because he's humble is is that you know he's from a town called Brantford Ontario which I'm familiar with because my cousins grew up there and I told Wayne once that my my uncle used to have a bookstore in in Brantford so I used to go there all the time and when I was a little kid it used to say home of Alexander Graham Bell right at Brantford Ontario now it's of course it's the Wayne Gretzky they're like screw the guy who invented the telephone and you know my acting career was very minimal
我父母也是这么认为的。所以随之而来的，我才搬到了多伦多。好吧，韦恩不会告诉你的是——因为他为人谦逊——其实他是从安大略省布兰特福德（Brantford）的一个小镇出来的。我很熟悉那里，因为我的表亲们在那儿长大。我曾告诉过韦恩，我叔叔以前在布兰特福德开过一家书店，所以我经常去那里。当我还是个小孩子的时候，布兰特福德市上赫然写着“亚历山大·格雷厄姆·贝尔（发明家）的故居”。而现在，当然了，那里成了“韦恩·格雷茨基的故居”。他们大概会想：去他的发明电话的家伙吧！你知道，我的演艺生涯非常短暂，
and and Lorne Michaels had asked me to host Saturday Night Live and I said no way I said I don't want to act I can't act I'm flying to Kentucky Derby and I'm reading the paper and it says Wayne Gretzky's gonna host Saturday Night Live and I remember I just pulled the paper down I looked at my wife and I go really and she goes one day you're gonna thank me for this so here I am in New York but the point and and I was so lucky because Mike Myers and Dana Carvey was so good they just carried me and John Lovitz but the point of my story was one of the most famous people ever to come from Brantford was Phil Hartman and I got to
而且洛恩·迈克尔斯（Lorne Michaels）曾邀请我去主持《周六夜现场》（Saturday Night Live），我说：“绝不！我不想演戏，我也不会演戏。”我当时正飞去肯塔基赛马会，我读着报纸，上面写着“韦恩·格雷茨基将主持《周六夜现场》”。我记得我把报纸拉下来，看着我妻子说：“真的吗？”她则说：“总有一天你会为此感谢我的。”于是我就这样来到了纽约。但重点是……我太幸运了，因为迈克·迈尔斯（Mike Myers）和达纳·卡维（Dana Carvey）太棒了，他们直接带飞了我，还有乔恩·洛维茨（John Lovitz）。我故事的重点是，从布兰特福德走出来的最著名的人物之一就是菲尔·哈特曼（Phil Hartman），我
know him that week during Saturday Night Live he was a genius he was a nice man and he always said to me you know I'm from Brantford too I go I know Phil I love it hey when you hey Wayne when you were a kid when you were living with that family that you didn't know I want to know about all the awkwardness I did this Kenny Rogers Christmas tour thank you many many years ago nobody wanted that's a tanking feeling I will put it later people and and on the tour a couple places we had to stay I like when they broke us up we had to stay with families it was so awkward it was like yeah hello you're sleeping in other people's
在《周六夜现场》的那周认识了他。他是个天才，是个好人。他总是对我说：“你知道吗，我也是布兰特福德人。”我说：“我知道，菲尔，我太喜欢了。”嘿，韦恩，嘿韦恩，当你还是个孩子的时候，当你和那个你不认识的家庭住在一起时，我想知道所有那些尴尬的经历。我很多年前做过肯尼·罗杰斯（Kenny Rogers）的圣诞巡演，谢谢。那真是一种令人崩溃的感觉，我得把这事记在后面。在巡演的几个地方，我们必须得留宿，我最讨厌他们把我们分开、让我们去寄宿在别人家里。那太尴尬了，就像：“哈喽，你睡在别人的……
bed you're eating there you don't know them I mean isn't that weird it was very weird at the beginning the first month I cried myself to sleep every night and of course my parents could hardly afford to call me so my dad worked for Bell Telephone and I knew every day at 430 one of his friends at Bell Telephone would get him a free line he could call me to see how I was doing and I'd always work my nerve up at 430 and say I'm doing great I love it it's no problem I'm getting accustomed to this I was 14 yeah and so here's the interesting part we became very close to the day they both passed they were like
床上，吃他们的饭，而你根本不认识他们。”我的意思是，这难道不是很诡异吗？刚开始的时候确实非常诡异。第一个月，我每天晚上都哭着入睡。当然，我父母根本打不起长途电话，所以我的爸爸在贝尔电话公司上班，我知道每天下午4点30分，他在贝尔电话公司的一个朋友会给他开通一条免费线路，这样他就能打电话问问我过得怎么样。我总是会在4点30分鼓起勇气说：“我过得很好！我喜欢这儿！没问题，我正在适应这一切。”我当时才14岁。所以，有趣的部分来了：直到他们俩去世，我们都保持着非常亲密的联系。他们就像是……
second parents to me I would always bring them out to games where they're played in LA or New York they'd always come in and treated me like their own son I true love with them and for them and they did for me and I said at the time and as I went through my career I said I'm never gonna do this to one of my kids so what happens I named my son Ty because I love baseball after Ty cop yeah and the age of 10 he looked at me he said you know dad I hate baseball okay so he wanted to be this hockey player so at 15 years old I said to him I said now listen I'm gonna tell you something that your grandfather would
对我来说就像是第二个父母，每当他们去洛杉矶或纽约比赛时，我总是带他们出去，他们总是来看我，把我当成自己的亲生儿子，我真心爱他们，他们也真心对我，就像他们为我做的那样，当时我这么说过，在我的职业生涯中我也说过，我绝对不会对我其中一个孩子这样做，结果呢？我给我的儿子取名叫泰，因为我喜欢棒球，是根据泰·柯布取的，对吧，他在10岁的时候看着我，他说，你知道吗，爸爸，我讨厌棒球，好吧，所以他想成为一名曲棍球运动员，所以在15岁的时候，我对他说，我告诉过你，我要告诉你一件事，你的爷爷会
tell you if you want to pursue this you got to leave the West Coast you got to go to Minnesota Boston I said you can go live with grandma and grandpa in my hometown and then we decided okay maybe you can go live with my mom and dad and then my mom unfortunately came down with cancer and I thought okay I don't want my 15 year old son to have to deal with this and go through it so he moved to Minnesota he went to a prep school in Minnesota he loved it at the end of the year he said you know what I want to come back home I just want to play hockey for fun I want to continue my education go to college and I said that's great you
对你说的，如果你想追求这个，你必须离开西海岸，你必须去明尼苏达、波士顿，我说你可以去我老家和爷爷奶奶一起住，然后我们决定，好吧，也许你可以去和我爸妈住在一起，然后我妈妈不幸患上了癌症，我想，好吧，我不想让我15岁的儿子不得不面对这个并经历这一切，所以他搬到了明尼苏达，他在明尼苏达的一所寄宿学校上学，他很喜欢那里，年底的时候他说，你知道吗，我想回家，我只是想为了好玩而打曲棍球，我想继续我的学业，上大学，我说那太棒了，你
know when you're 30 years old you look back and say you know how I gave it an honest effort I don't I don't regret anything I did he loved the school loved everything about it he moved home and I said to him one day I said what was one of the things that really bothered you about moving there and playing there other than missing your mother he said you know I got tired of every guy that I played against saying you're not as good as your dad so I said to him I said so what would you say to them and he said it was pretty easy I just say I got news for you you're not as good as he is either you know when you know the one
你知道当你30岁的时候，你会回过头来说，你知道我是如何全力以赴的，我没有，我不后悔我做过的任何事，他很喜欢那所学校，喜欢那里的每一件事，他搬回了家，有一天我对他说，除了想念你妈妈之外，真正让你感到困扰的是什么？他说，你知道的，我厌倦了每个与我对抗的人都说，你不如你爸爸好，所以我对他说，我问他，你会对他们说什么？他说这很简单，我只会说，我有个消息要告诉你，你也没有他那么好，你知道的，当你知道这其中一
of the things that I just sort of know I have noticed before but it just kind of came into focus you know listen you tell the story is is that you know obviously one of the things being this being who you are and having this illustrious career and all the things you did it's brought you all the way around the world you've met all sorts of people and all sorts of walks of life and you're talking about going and living with a family when you're 14 whatever you've been around people your whole life and you you have a gift for talking to people and really listening to people and really engaging with them
件事情，我之前只是隐约注意到，但现在它变得清晰起来，你知道的，听你讲述这个故事，很显然，作为拥有这种身份、拥有如此辉煌的职业生涯以及做过所有这些事情的人，它把你带到了世界各地，你遇到了各种各样的人，来自社会各阶层，你谈到在14岁左右时去和一个家庭一起生活，你一生都在和人们打交道，你有一种天赋，能够与人交谈，真正倾听人们的心声，真正与他们互动
and I and you are such a and more than just an ambassador for hockey you're such a just listen you talk and the way that you talk to your kids I I don't know there's something I really admire about the way that you relate to human beings and the way you connect with other human beings I think it's awesome and is that something that you was your relationship like that with your were your parents like that did they bestow that upon you I know your dad was a really gregarious guys the most famous Leaf fan of all time next to me yeah that's true yeah well where did that sort of is that where that came from do you think no I'll tell
而且我，你不仅是曲棍球的大使，你简直就是，听你说话，你跟孩子们说话的方式，我不知道，我对你与人交往的方式以及你与他人建立联系的方式有着一种由衷的钦佩，我觉得这太棒了，这是否是你的，你和你的父母的关系也是这样的吗？你的父母也是这样吗？他们把这传给了你吗？我知道你爸爸是一个非常热情的人，他是除了我之外有史以来最著名的枫叶队球迷，对吧，这倒是真的，对吧，好吧，那这种性格是从哪儿来的，你觉得是那样吗？不，我来告诉
you what I was the shyest kid you could ever meet I was quiet you know my dad used to say to me the good Lord gave you two ears and one mouth for a reason listen twice as much as you talk and I lived by that I was this kid who was in school that if you had to get up and give a speech I'd be sweating bullets and like every other 14 15 year old when I moved to Toronto and this is the rest of my story they had one son and he was a character and he was two years older than I was and he was this outgoing full-of-life energy young man and we're still close today and he really helped me sort of mature and come out of my shell
你吧，我是你能见到的最害羞的孩子，我很安静，你知道的，我爸爸过去常常对我说，上帝给你两只耳朵和一张嘴是有原因的，听的比说的多一倍，我一直遵循这个原则，我在学校里是个这样的孩子，如果你必须站起来演讲，我会急得直冒汗，就像其他14、15岁的孩子一样，当我搬到多伦多时，这是我故事的剩余部分，他们只有一个儿子，他个性十足，比我大两岁，他是一个外向、充满生命力的年轻男子，我们至今仍很亲密，他真的帮我变得成熟，走出了自己的壳
as far as talking to people and talking with people listening to people and I just think it was a progression and I just learned you know I always say to people when you meet your idol and listen there's been a lot of times where you meet somebody and you go wow that guy was having a bad day he wasn't as nice as I thought he was gonna be or that person wasn't as great as I had him built up in in my mind and my childhood idol was Gordie Howe from the time I was I could think of Gordie Howe three years old I used to even go to the barber shop and say can I get a Gordie Howe haircut that's how much I love Gordie Howe
就跟人交谈、与人对话、倾听别人而言，我只是觉得这是一个过程，我只是学到了，你知道的，我总是对人们说，当你见到你的偶像时，听着，有很多次你见到某个人，你会想，哇，那家伙今天心情不好，他没有我想象的那么好，或者那个人没有我在脑海和童年时代塑造的那么伟大，我的童年偶像库尔迪·豪，从我记事起我就能想到库尔迪·豪，三岁的时候，我甚至去理发店说，我能剪一个库尔迪·豪的发型吗？我就是这样深爱着库尔迪·豪
and through hockey him I became a planet of the apes haircuts and through hockey Gordie and I became best friends we were very close he was like a second dad to me what about like interviews though like to will's question yeah yeah I got I got comfortable interviews at 14 15 16 yeah before that you were like petrified yeah I was scared to death you know head would be down kind of shy stutter a lot all that kind of stuff and you know you know who I met at a young age in my career that was incredibly helpful with me off the ice was a great Canadian Alan Thick he was he was energetic he was smart you know and he
通过曲棍球，我和他，我变成了人猿星球发型，通过库尔迪·豪，我和库尔迪成了最好的朋友，我们非常亲密，他就像我的第二个父亲一样，不过采访呢？威尔的问题是怎样的？对，对，我在14、15、16岁时就对采访感到自如了，对，在那之前你就像是被吓呆了一样，对，我吓得要死，你知道，总是低着头，有点害羞，结巴得很厉害，诸如此类的事情，你知道的，在我职业生涯的早期，我遇到了一个对我在冰球场外非常有帮助的人，那就是伟大的加拿大人艾伦·锡克，他充满活力，他很聪明，你知道，他
would help me do things and he would help me and you always say to me Wayne you know instead of giving a standard interview an athlete gives here's things that I think can help you and here's kind of things you can chat about and talk about so Alan was a huge influence in my life wonderful man as a matter of fact I was staying at Alan's house the day I got traded the LA Kings in August of 1988 I was down there for a week all the day and I got a phone call you've been traded to LA and I said Alan you don't mind if I kick you out of your house and move in that way you guys are like special guy
会帮我做一些事情，他会帮我，你总是对我说，韦恩，与其进行运动员常说的那种标准采访，这里有些我认为可以帮到你的事情，这里有些你可以聊聊和谈论的事情，所以艾伦对我的生活产生了巨大的影响，一个了不起的人，事实上，就在我被交易到洛杉矶国王队的那个日子，也就是1988年8月，我正住在艾伦的家里，我在那儿待了一个星期，就在那天我接到了一个电话，说你被交易到洛杉矶了，我说艾伦，你不介意把我赶出你家然后我搬进来吧，你们就像是特别的人
Sean I know you knew Alan to our friend Jimmy Brose he what a sweet he's the greatest super funny and I've played golf twice in my life and one of them was with Jimmy and Alan yeah okay and wait Sean can I also tell you this Wayne I'll tell you this yeah and when in 1988 when you got traded I was doing a summer theater theater you were you're playing special hockey at the highest level in October and I was that I was at a theater program in London England so anyway but when I found out the news and there was no internet it would just came across on the news and it was such big news it was in the UK it was like in
肖恩，我知道你通过我们的朋友吉米·布罗斯认识艾伦，他多么亲切啊，他是最棒的，超级有趣，我这辈子打过两次高尔夫，其中一次就是和吉米还有艾伦一起，对吧，等等，肖恩，我也可以告诉你这个吗？韦恩，我告诉你这个，对，当1988年你被交易的时候，我在做暑期戏剧，你在10月份以最高水平打特殊冰球，而我在英国伦敦的一个戏剧项目里，所以无论如何，但当我发现这个消息时，当时还没有互联网，这只是在新闻上播出的，这是一个如此重大的新闻，它甚至在英国登上了
the evening paper whatever and my buddy and I found this Canadian pub down in Covent Garden and we went to the Canadian and we just had about 30 beers because we were like Wayne's going to America I had I had a wonderful London story I was there is it Hyde Park right yeah they have Canada Day there which is this huge day that it's all these Canadians come down they set up these ball hockey rinks there's about six of them teams sign up so all these Canadians flock down there they have Canadian French fries and fish and chips they have Canadian bands that come out tragically hip and they play during the day so I'm
晚报之类的，我和我的朋友在科芬园附近找到了一家加拿大酒吧，我们去了那家加拿大酒吧，喝了大约30杯啤酒，因为我们当时觉得，韦恩要去美国了，我有一个美妙的伦敦故事，我在那里，那是海德公园，对吧，他们在那里举办加拿大日，这是一个盛大的节日，所有这些加拿大人都会来，他们搭建了这些冰球场，大约有六个，各个队伍报名参加，所以所有这些加拿大人都涌向那里，他们吃着加拿大的炸薯条和炸鱼薯条，有加拿大的乐队来表演，比如悲伤曲调合唱团，他们在白天演出，所以我
standing there with my two boys and I said let's go watch this hockey game so him my two boys and I we get behind the net now these guys are intense they're older men probably drinking beer running around their shoes whacking and hacking each other and it's really intense and there's this guy standing beside me with a team Canada Gretzky jersey on and I turned to the guy and I'm trying to make conversation I was gonna sign his autograph or get a picture with him and I said hey this game is pretty intense and he just keeps staring straight out he goes yeah this is crazy and I said are you having fun today and he goes yeah
站在那里，带着我的两个儿子，我说我们去看这场曲棍球比赛吧，于是他、我的两个儿子和我，我们来到了球门后面，现在这些家伙都很拼，他们是年长的男士，可能喝着啤酒，穿着鞋子跑来跑去，互相挥杆冲撞，真的非常激烈，我旁边站着一个穿着加拿大队格雷茨基球衣的家伙，我转向那家伙，试图挑起对话，我打算让他签名或者合影，我说，嘿，这场比赛真激烈，他只是目视前方，说道，是啊，这太疯狂了，我说，你今天玩得开心吗？他回答，是啊，
this is unbelievable and I said to my two boys I said let's go and they go aren't you gonna sign that form I said I give him two chances to turn to me I'm not giving him a third we're out of here and that was my London story yeah give you a break I'm trying to watch the game now the court now I'm just back to the like the actual sport of hockey and me like like you know what Wayne if me and you just me and you had dinner I would have a bunch of different questions than Jason will probably so these are one of my dumb questions a lot of musical theater stuff I don't know if it's you probably more of a snack than a meal
这太不可思议了，我对我的两个儿子说，我们走吧，他们说，你不是要去要签名吗？我说，我给他两次转向我的机会，我不会给他第三次机会的，我们走吧，这就是我的伦敦故事，好吧，让你休息一下，我正试图看比赛呢，现在，现在我只是回到了像曲棍球这样的实际运动中，如果我和你，仅仅我和你一起吃晚餐，我可能会问出一堆跟杰森不同类型的问题，所以这些是我的蠢问题之一，很多音乐剧方面的东西，我不知道，也许对你来说这只是点心，算不上大餐
no like just the art of hockey playing okay so the coordination to me not knowing anything about it looks impossible it's like playing the drums you need your feet and your arms and your brains and everything and so you're gonna laugh at this question is there any because of the athleticism are there any guys who go from hockey to figure skating or figure skating to hockey because they're both like you know you watch these hockey guys you know you watch the hockey guys like when you could do other things that walk because you have the skill of skating you know what I mean actually it's a it's a really good
不，就像曲棍球运动的艺术一样，好吧，对于一无所知的我来说，协调性看起来是不可能的，这就像打鼓一样，你需要你的脚、你的手臂、你的大脑以及所有东西，所以你会嘲笑这个问题，因为这种运动能力，有没有人从曲棍球转向花样滑冰，或者从花样滑冰转向曲棍球，因为它们都是，你知道的，你看着这些曲棍球手，你知道的，你看着曲棍球手，就像当你能做除了走路之外的其他事情，因为你具备滑冰的技能，你知道我的意思吗？其实这是一个非常
question because one of the things that my wife who was a dancer always says that she would always say to me you should do ballet because ballet is gonna help your hockey and I go I don't know when I take my skates off the rhythm just leaves my body ballet wouldn't be good for me yeah but there are guys that start off in figure skating that at 9 10 11 switch over it's probably easier to go that way than to play ice hockey and then go into figure skating I'll tell you why in ice hockey you're skating more like downhill skiing so you're kind of sitting on your squads yeah you're squatting and the blades are
好的问题，因为我的妻子曾是一名舞蹈演员，她总是说的一件事是，她总是对我说，你应该跳芭蕾，因为芭蕾会对你的曲棍球有帮助，而我说，我不知道，当我脱下冰鞋时，节奏就从我体内消失了，芭蕾对我不适用，对，但确实有些人是从花样滑冰开始的，然后在9岁、10岁、11岁时转行，从那个方向转过来可能比打冰球然后转去花样滑冰要容易，我来告诉你为什么，在冰球中，你的滑冰方式更像是高山滑雪，所以你有点像是在做深蹲
actually flat so you're kind of moving like that whereas figure skating because of the toe picks you're more straight up and you're more I guess right and so it's two different sort of skating formulas so it's tough to go from one to the other but okay it's a real good question actually wait Wayne I want to ask you one question not to get too deep in the weeds on hockey so because these guys won't get it but I have to clear this up once and for all back in the day Wayne was one of the first guys in hockey to wear a Jofa helmet how did that happen I've always wanted to know about the Jofa so I don't know if these
对，你在下蹲，冰刀其实是平的，所以你有点像那样移动，而花样滑冰因为有鞋头齿，你更直立，而且我猜更，没错，所以这是两种不同的滑冰方式，因此从一种转到另一种很难，不过，好吧，这确实是个好问题，等等，韦恩，我想问你一个问题，虽然不想在曲棍球的细节上纠缠太深，因为这些家伙不会懂，但我必须一劳永逸地澄清这一点，当年韦恩是曲棍球界第一个戴约法头盔的人之一，那是怎么发生的？我一直想知道关于约法头盔的事，所以我不知道这些
guys know but when I turned pro when I was 17 and my dad said because he had to sign the contract to validate it because I wasn't 18 and he said two things I'll sign this but you're gonna finish 12th grade I don't care what you do you're gonna go to school to your 18 years old so I said okay I'll do that so my first practice and in those days the players would come to the younger guys or the new guys and say hey take your helmet off you shouldn't play with a helmet because that's kind of what guys did back then so here I am I took my helmet off and my dad's at my first exhibition game we're playing in Indianapolis, Indiana
家伙知不知道，当我17岁转为职业球员时，我父亲说，因为他必须签署合同来使之生效，因为我还没满18岁，他说两件事，我会在这个上签字，但你得读完12年级，我不管你做什么，你得去上学直到18岁，所以我说，好吧，我会的，所以在我的第一场训练中，在那个年代，老队员会走到年轻球员或新队员面前说，嘿，把你的头盔摘了，你不应该戴着头盔打球，因为那是当时大家常做的事，所以我就把头盔摘了，我父亲在我第一场表演赛时也在场，我们在印第安纳州印第安纳波利斯比赛
and I'm out there skating around and all of a sudden my dad comes running down the stairs at the arena and yelling at me get your goddamn helmet back on so I'm turning to one of the guys and I said my dad said I have to put my helmet on so we go to the locker room and I get this helmet and one of the guys said Wayne wear this Jove helmet it's like not wearing a helmet and I was like okay so I get the helmet on and I wore it my whole career I was comfortable with it I got traded or sold to Edmonton I got traded or sold a couple times in my career played a lot of years I got sold a lot so I get sold to Edmonton and I'm
我在冰上滑来滑去，突然我父亲从竞技场的楼梯上跑下来，冲着我大喊，把你的该死的头盔戴回去！所以我转向其中一个队员，我说我父亲说我必须把头盔戴上，于是我们回到更衣室，我拿到了这个头盔，其中一个队员说，韦恩，戴上这个约法头盔吧，这感觉就像没戴头盔一样，我就想，好吧，所以我戴上了头盔，并在我的整个职业生涯中都戴着它，我对此感到很舒适，我被交易或出售给埃德蒙顿，我的职业生涯中被交易或出售过好几次，打了好多年，我经常被出售，所以我被出售到了埃德蒙顿，我
going to high school in Edmonton and the principal doesn't know I am now Edmonton travels more than other teams and so I've gone on the road for five days or seven days you were going to high school in Edmonton when you were playing there yeah and the WHA and the principal calls me in like early January said young man you're gonna be a nothing you're gonna mount to nobody you're schooling this and that I should kick you out and I said to him look give me till January 26th and he goes what's that I go I turn 18 January 26th if I'm still messing up you can call me in and kick me out of the school so the guy
在埃德蒙顿上高中，校长不知道我是谁，现在埃德蒙顿比其他球队旅行更多，所以我出差去了五天或七天，你在那里打球的时候还在埃德蒙顿上高中？是的，在WHA世界曲棍球协会的时候，校长在1月上旬把我叫去说，年轻人，你将来会一事无成，你不会有什么出息，你的学业这样那样，我应该把你开除，我对他说，听着，给我到1月26日的时间，他问，那是什麽？我说我1月26日就满18岁了，如果我还在胡闹，你可以把我叫来开除出学校，于是那家伙
goes okay I'll do that for you so January 26th and I used to pick up one of my teammates daughter was in my classes we're the same age so driving to school and I'm kind of singing to the music in the car and she goes well you're pretty happy that I said yeah I'm quitting school I'm going in and telling that principal I'm done I walked in the principal's office I said you know what I just want to thank you for not kicking me out of school I quit and I lived up to what my dad wanted so listener there you know there's a physical element to hockey you know it's a contact sport and sometimes things can get rough and tumble
说，好吧，我为你这么做；所以1月26日那天，我过去常接我的一位队友的女儿，她在我的班里，我们同岁，所以在开车去学校的路上，我一边在车里跟着音乐唱歌，她就说，哇，你挺高兴的嘛，我说，对啊，我不上学了，我要进去告诉那个校长我再也不念了，我走进了校长的办公室，我说，你知道吗，我只是想感谢你没有把我开除出学校，我不上了，我实现了我父亲想要的心愿，所以听众朋友们，你知道的，曲棍球中有一个身体对抗的元素，你知道它是一项接触性运动，有时事情会变得粗暴
and there can be fights and stuff like that Wayne was famously you know kind of above that fray never really got into a whole lot of fights but a lot of the the heavies on the other side would love to try to get him into that because they want him off the ice but you always managed to avoid it was there ever a time in your career when everybody was kind of the same size before they got huge huge where you kind of tried to incorporate that into part of your game and and went wow that hurt that my face is real sore and you just was like you know what I'm just gonna be the finesse guy that I was born and and what is the
并且可能会有打架之类的事情，韦恩以历来置身于这种争端之上而闻名，从来没有真正卷入过很多打架，但对方阵营的很多重量级人物都很乐意试图把他拉进去，因为他们想让他离开冰场，但你总是设法避开它，在你的职业生涯中，有没有那么一段时间，大家在变得无比巨大之前都差不多大，你曾试图将那融入你比赛的一部分，然后心想，哇，那真疼，我的脸真酸，然后你就想，你知道吗，我还是做我天生就要做的那种技术型球员吧，而且，最严重的
worst injury I don't know about you guys but if I get punched in the nose I start crying I'm always amazed at these guys they go back and forth back and forth and they just drop their gloves they go to the penalty box they sit there for five minutes and they come back out and they go wow and you know I think I had one fight in my career and this is a really funny story I won Sports Illustrated Sportsman of the Year which to me was one of my favorite awards that I ever won so so the publisher of Sports Illustrated flies to Edmonton to present this award and he's at center ice and he's talking
伤是什么？我不知道你们怎么样，如果我的鼻子挨了一拳，我就会开始哭，我总是对这些人感到惊叹，他们来回推搡，然后直接扔下手套，走向惩罚席，坐在那里五分钟，然后又走出来，感觉棒极了，你知道，我想我的职业生涯中打过一次架，这是一个非常有趣的故事，我赢得了《体育画报》年度最佳运动员，对我来说，这是我赢得的自己最喜欢的奖项之一，所以《体育画报》的出版商飞到埃德蒙顿来颁发这个奖，他站在球场中央，在谈论
about my sportsmanship and what he brings to the game and he's going on and on I'm in the second shift of that game and I got into a fight the only fight I've ever had I come back to the bench and not one guy said good fight or good job they all said what were you thinking the guy the guy who was from Minnesota Neil Brotten and him and I still laugh about today because it was so silly and my my buddy who was a tough guy at the time one of the tougher guys ever to play who's that Dave Semenko and he turns me he says Wayne you got five minutes for cat fighting that was my last fight was it a pretty funny
我的体育精神以及我给这项比赛带来的东西，他喋喋不休地说个不停，我在那场比赛的第二个换人轮次中，就打了一架，我打过的唯一的一次架，我回到替补席，没有一个人说打得好或干得好，他们全都说你在想什么呢？那个家伙，那个来自明尼苏达的家伙叫尼尔·布罗滕，我和他直到今天还会拿这事开玩笑，因为实在是太傻了，我那个当时是个硬汉的朋友，是有史以来最硬的球员之一，那是谁？戴夫·塞门科，他转过身对我说，韦恩，你因为猫打架被罚了五分钟，那是我的最后一次打架，那是一场挺有趣的
fight it was our clear winner nothing it was kind of like one of these right yeah one one night we were playing in Chicago and this guy and I had enough of them and I kind of grabbed him and he threw me down on the ground and he's standing over top of me like this and I'm looking at our bench and there's five players with legs over top like they're riding a horse right yeah ready to jump on the ice and he's standing over top like this and he goes don't move I'm not gonna hit you and I said don't worry I'm not moving I come back to the bench and I said all right he could have beat the crap out of me nobody's allowed to touch that guy so
打架吗？根本没有明确的赢家，它有点像那种，对，有一天我们在芝加哥比赛，这个家伙和我受够了他，我一把抓住了他，他把我摔倒在地上，他像这样站在我上面，我看着我们的替补席，有五个球员把腿搭在挡板上，就像他们在骑马一样，对，准备跳上冰面，他就像这样站在上面，然后说，别动，我不会打你的，我说，别担心，我没动，我回到替补席，我说，好吧，他本来可以把我痛打一顿的，没人敢碰那家伙，所以
I said he would have hit me he would have had a couple more fights before the night was over oh yeah and it's the punching of the helmets too that I I mean they'd never seem to really hurt their hands and they're just slugging oh they do yeah now they have visors on too they have visors and then and then if you fight if you start a fight there's like the whole code that if you keep your visor on that you're a you know you're you're a jerk because you're not you're gonna let the other guy hurt himself wait I remember I remember this yeah good no I'm just gonna say we'll know this there's a few guys there were
我说，如果他打了我的话，在当晚结束之前他肯定还得再打几场架，哦，是的，而且他们还捶打头盔，我意思是，他们似乎从来没有真正伤到手，只是在那儿猛挥，哦，他们会的，现在他们也戴上面罩了，他们有面罩，然后如果你打架，如果你挑起打架，这里有一整套规矩，如果你戴着面罩，你就是个混蛋，因为你没有，你要让对方受伤，等等，我记得，我记得这个，好，不，我只是想说，我们会知道的，有几个人是
Hall of Fame type players that also could fight the question you were asking me one of his buddies Brendan Shanahan and Mark Messier those guys were not only Hall of Famers at what they did but they were also as tough as anybody ever played the game yeah yeah you know Wayne Shanahan once called me about a month after he retired and he was like it was like a Wednesday afternoon he was kind of blue and I said what's going on you all right and he goes I just realized I'm never gonna fight again I said buddy you're 40 you're 40 you're 42 you shouldn't be fighting anymore anyway what are you talking about and he's
名人堂级别的球员，他们也能打架，你刚才问我的那个人，他的好朋友布伦丹·沙纳汉和马克·梅西尔，这些家伙不仅在他们所做的事情上是名人堂成员，而且他们也和有史以来打过冰球的任何人一样强硬，对，对，你知道吗，韦恩，沙纳汉在我退役大约一个月后曾打电话给我，当时就像是一个周三的下午，他有点郁闷，我问怎么了，你还好吗？他说，我刚刚意识到我再也不会打架了，我说，老兄，你40岁了，你40岁，你42岁了，无论如何你都不应该再打架了，你在说什么呢？而他是
genuinely disappointed yeah he was he was like he was just kind of bummed out you know so Wayne so you go your life changes you're you're you move out of the house when you're 14 you go play in Toronto you play how many years of junior to play just just one right or not even you played for the Sioux yeah I played one year in Sioux Saint-Marie is a 16 year old as a 16 year old I mean which is you guys have to understand it's so crazy what Wayne did he was just ahead like he played on teams that were he was young as he told you yet the youngest by about four years and the parents of the other teams were still
真心感到失望，对，他当时就像是，他只是有点沮丧，你知道的，所以韦恩，你经历着，你的生活发生了改变，你14岁就搬出了家，你去多伦多打球，你打了多少年的青年联赛？只打了一年对吧？甚至还不到？你为苏圣玛丽队效力，对，我在苏圣玛丽队打了一年，作为一个16岁的少年，作为一个16岁的少年，这意味着你们必须明白，韦恩所做的事情是多么疯狂，他当时就像是超前了，他效力于那些队员都比他大的球队，正如他所告诉你的，他是所有人里年纪最小的，比其他人小了大约四岁，而其他球队的家长仍然
mad at him because he was scoring so many goals I played in Sioux Saint-Marie and if you've never been to Sioux Saint-Marie it's just above Sioux Michigan so it's about eight hours north by car from Toronto and the snow is about six feet deep early December till late March and we flew around on a DC three now no way flying is one thing but try getting in a DC three and the pilot comes back and says we need two of the heavier guides go to the front to the lighter guys go to the back yeah I ride to pretty much every game like this yeah and it can only fly at 9,000 feet right and you're right in the middle of those
对很不满，因为他进了太多球，我在苏圣玛丽队打过球，如果你从来没去过苏圣玛丽队，它就在密歇根州苏市的正上方，开车从多伦多往北大约要八个小时，从12月初到3月下旬，雪有六英尺深，我们坐DC-3型飞机四处飞行，现在，坐飞机是一回事，但试着挤进一架DC-3里，飞行员走回来说，我们需要两个比较重的人去前面，比较轻的人去后面，对，我几乎每场比赛都是这样坐飞机的，而且它只能在9000英尺的高度飞行，对吧，你正好位于那些
snow clouds going into Sioux Saint-Marie every trip I was the singer Ricky Valens that's all I kept thinking was this is not good this DC three is not fun but I ended up having a fun time there no we'll be right back smartness is sponsored by better help everything you get in life comes with a manual get a new car comes to the manual you get a microwave it comes with a manual you buy a television it comes with the manual everything in life comes with a manual except life anytime you come up against anything wouldn't it be nice to have a manual that you could refer to you could something comes up and
雪云的正中央，每次去苏圣玛丽队的旅程中，我都是歌手里奇·瓦伦斯，我脑子里一直想着的是，这可真不妙，这架DC-3一点也不好玩，但我最后在那儿过得很愉快，不，我们马上回来，SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助，你生活中得到的所有东西都附带使用说明书，买辆新车，附带说明书，买个微波炉，附带说明书，买台电视机，附带说明书，生活中的一切都附带说明书，除了生活本身，每当你遇到任何事情时，如果有一本可以参考的说明书，当有什么事情发生时
you could say hang on a second you flip to that page and you go okay this is how I deal with this unfortunately life doesn't come with the user manual so when it's not working for you it's normal to feel stuck you think you've got a good handle on how to talk to people until you get into a place where you feel like you're not able to really articulate what's going on or what sort of complex position you have on something and you're kind of stuck you don't know you don't have the words you don't have the language you don't have the tools to work your way through that or to get that language to deal with
你可以说，等一下，你翻到那一页，然后说，好吧，这就是我处理这件事的方法，不幸的是，生活并没有附带用户手册，所以当它对你不适用时，感到陷入困境是很正常的，你以为你很清楚如何与人交谈，直到你进入这样一个地方，你觉得你无法真正表达到底发生了什么，或者你对某事有什么样复杂的立场，然后你有点卡住了，你不知道，你没有词汇，你没有语言，你没有工具来解决这个问题，或者无法获得那种语言来应对
something to express yourself about a tough situation you're in that's totally normal well guess what that's what therapy does working with a therapist helps you cut through all that and really bring into focus the things that you're trying to talk about and work on as the world's largest therapy service and better help is matched three million people with professionally licensed and vetted therapists available 100% online plus it's affordable you just fill out a brief questionnaire to match with a therapist and if things aren't clicking you can easily switch to a new therapist anytime
某事，来表达你对自己所处的困境的感受，这完全是很正常的，好吧，你猜怎么着？这就是疗法所做的事情，与治疗师合作可以帮助你切断这一切，并真正聚焦于你试图讨论和解决的事情，作为全球最大的疗法服务机构，BetterHelp已经将300万人与获得专业执照且经过审查的治疗师进行了匹配，100%在线提供，此外它价格实惠，你只需填写一份简短的问卷即可与治疗师匹配，如果感觉不对劲，你可以随时轻松地更换新治疗师
it could be simpler no waiting rooms no traffic no endless searching for the right therapist learn more and save 10% off your first month at betterhelp.com slash smartlist that's better help H-E-L-P dot com slash smartlist smartlist is brought to you in part by nationwide pet sweaters I love them you love them your pet may feel differently nonetheless sweater weather is here and that means the holiday season is in full swing big holiday celebrations can be fun for both pets and humans but you need to be careful our friends at nationwide have put together some holiday safety tips for you and your pets well it seems natural to give a dog a bone bones especially turkey bones are
这再简单不过了，没有候诊室，没有交通拥堵，没有无休止地寻找合适的治疗师，请访问betterhelp.com/smartlist了解更多信息并节省首月10％的费用，网址是betterhelp.com/smartlist，Smartlist部分内容由Nationwide宠物毛衣赞助，我喜欢它们，你喜欢它们，你的宠物可能会有不同的感受，尽管如此，毛衣天气已经来临，这意味着假日季正如火如荼地展开，盛大的节日庆祝活动对宠物和人类来说都很有趣，但你需要小心，我们的Nationwide好友为你们和你们的宠物整理了一些假日安全提示
super dangerous for dogs just so you know they may be pretty but some holiday decorative plants are poisonous even deadly a single leaf from any lily variety is lethal to cats other plants like mistletoe can cause pretty serious stomach upset when the unexpected happens nationwide is there to protect your pets from Thanksgiving to New Year's Day and every day thereafter get reimbursed for eligible expenses related to injuries illnesses and more go to pet insurance comm slash smartlist to get a quote today nationwide is on your side and back to the show but wait I was gonna say so you go you go through all
虽然给狗一根骨头似乎很自然，但骨头，尤其是火鸡骨头，对狗来说超级危险，大家要知道，它们可能很好看，但一些节日装饰植物是有毒的甚至是致命的，百合花类的单片叶子对猫来说是致命的，其他植物比如槲寄生会导致相当严重的肠胃不适，当意外发生时，Nationwide随时准备保护你的宠物，从感恩节到元旦以及此后的每一天，获得与伤害、疾病等相关的符合条件费用的报销，立即访问petinsurance.com/smartlist获取报价，Nationwide始终在你身边，回到节目中，但是等等，我正要说，所以你经历了
that stuff Wayne and then you you know you and then you go into the NHL well first you go to the WHA with with before that Indianapolis then Edmonton the WHA I've always wanted to this two questions I guess yeah playing in the WHA was because they was it was a rival league they tried to start up it was a startup league Sean that to try to rival the NHL and then they ended up merging a few teams was that like the Blitz it was kind of like the ABA in the basketball was it an advantage to you a little bit playing a little bit in the WHA before the NHL yeah yeah no question you know the WHA wasn't as good
所有这些事情，韦恩，然后你，你知道的，你然后进入了NHL，好吧，首先你去了WHA，在那之前是印第安纳波利斯，然后是埃德蒙顿，WHA，我一直想问这个问题，两个问题吧，在WHA打球是因为，它们是一个竞争联盟，他们试图建立起来，肖恩，那是一个初创联盟，试图与NHL竞争，然后他们最终合并了几支球队，这就像是闪电战吗？它有点像篮球里的ABA吗？在进入NHL之前，在WHA打一点球对你来说算是一种优势吗？对，对，毫无疑问，你知道，WHA没有
as the NHL and they were stealing all the young players so there was like 12 of us are under the age of 20 that signed at the end of that year the NHL said okay we we got to come together so four teams dismantled and four teams went into the NHL and emerged it was a good league it was it as good as the NHL absolutely not but it was a good stepping stone for me to get one year under my belt living with men playing with men traveling like the men do boy in Edmonton there's a lot of travel trust me we were a long way from I think our closest trip was two and a half hours to Winnipeg yeah but but it was a good it was a good stepping
NHL那么好，他们一直在挖走所有年轻球员，所以我们当中大约有12人年龄在20岁以下，在那年底签了约，NHL说，好吧，我们必须走到一起，所以四支球队解散了，四支球队进入了NHL并进行了合并，这是一个不错的联盟，它有NHL那么好吗？绝对没有，但它对我来说是一个很好的跳板，让我在成年人的陪伴下生活了一年，和成年人一起打球，像成年人一样到处奔波，天哪，在埃德蒙顿，有大量的客场旅行，相信我，我们离得很远，我想我们最近的行程是到温尼伯两个半小时
stone for me so you go you do that but my point is this from a young age and then you go in and you're thrust into this and you're just you explode on this I mean I know I know a lot of your stats just I'm not reading anywhere off the top of my head I remember the season when you scored 215 points I remember you know I mean all of it to me was just incredible but for you with that came a lot of responsibility and a lot of money and all of a sudden you're thrust into the business of hockey were you prepared for that aspect of superstardom some ways I was in other ways I wasn't my priority and my focus was just to play hockey I
对，但对我来说，那是一个很好的跳板，所以你去了，你做了那些，但我的重点是，从很小的时候开始，然后你进去，你被推到了这个位置上，你简直就爆发了，我的意思是，我，我了解你的很多数据，我甚至不需要看任何地方，就随口说出，我记得你得到215分的那个赛季，我记得，我的意思是，这一切对我来说都不可思议，但对你来说，随之而来的是大量的责任和巨额资金，突然之间你被推入了曲棍球的商业世界，你为超级巨星的那个方面做好准备了吗？在某些方面是的，在其他方面我没有，我的首要任务和重点只是打冰球，我
let everything around me just kind of be itself and I never really concerned myself with things like that I really got more heavily involved when I went to LA when I got traded to LA I remember we were driving by the tennis courts on Van Nuys Boulevard and I remember as we're driving by I said to my wife I said you know if this was Canada there'd be 15 kids out there playing ball hockey right now that's just the way it is and two years later I went by that same tennis courts and there was a big sign that said no roller hockey allowed and I said you know what hockey's coming a long way more kids are playing it
让周围的一切顺其自然，我从不真正关心那样的事情，自我去洛杉矶以来，我更多地参与其中，自我被交易到洛杉矶以来，我记得我们开车经过范奈斯大道的网球场，我记得当我们开车经过时，我对妻子说，你知道，如果是加拿大，现在外面会有15个孩子在打街头冰球，情况就是这样，两年后，我路过同一个网球场，那里有一个大牌子，上面写着“严禁轮滑冰球”，我说，你知道吗，曲棍球已经取得了长足的进步，越来越多的孩子在玩它
it's growing it's advancing and so I learned more about the the marketing and the business side of the game when I went to LA and then Michael Eisner used to come to all the games and he loved hockey and Michael decided okay I'm gonna do this movie the mighty ducks he did the movie nobody thought they would ever have an NHL team called the Anaheim mighty ducks and so he was a huge part of the success of a national hockey league going to another level and then it just kind of snowballed from there San Jose and then of course Denver and Dallas and Phoenix you know when when you when you do something as great as
它在成长，在推进，所以当我去了洛杉矶之后，我更多地了解了这项运动的市场和商业方面，然后迈克尔·埃斯纳过去常来看所有的比赛，他喜欢曲棍球，迈克尔决定，好吧，我要拍这部电影《野鸭突击队》，他拍了这部电影，没有人会想到他们会拥有一支名为阿纳海姆巨鸭队的NHL球队，所以他是国家冰球联盟走向另一个水平的巨大成功的一部分，然后它就像滚雪球一样从那里发展起来，圣何塞，当然还有丹佛、达拉斯和菲尼克斯，你知道，当你，当你做了一些像
you do and and as far as long as you do it becomes an addiction I'm sure yeah like you can't wait to get on the ice that like you were describing right yeah listen people ask me all the time do you miss hockey yeah I'm sick that I can't play but I'm 61 and I'm slow and I'm not good but every day I get up and say gosh I wish I could play yeah but I mean do you so when you pass an ice rink or a or it's winter time do you do you still go on the ice and not play but just experience that I you know my son does some hockey schools and I'll get on the ice periodically and I don't really skate I just kind of get out there yeah
你做的那样伟大、坚持了那么久的事情时，它就会变成一种瘾，我敢肯定，是的，就像你迫不及待地想上冰场一样，就像你刚才描述的那样，对，听着，人们总是问我，你想念曲棍球吗？我很痛苦我不能打球了，但我61岁了，我很慢，而且我打得不好，但我每天醒来都说，天哪，我希望我能打球，对，但我的意思是，你，所以当你路过一个冰场或，或者正值冬天时，你还会去冰场，不是去打球，而是去体验那种感觉吗？我知道，我儿子参加一些曲棍球学校，我会偶尔上冰，我其实不怎么滑冰，我只是到那儿去转转
but I used to play in a lot of I guess charity events charity games people would say hey Wayne we jump in I go yeah I'll play a couple shifts and I came home one time was about seven years ago I was about 54 years old and I put my bag down and I turned to Janet and I said you know it's the last time I'm ever gonna skate and she goes what are you talking about and I said it was the first time in my life that I was scared on the ice that if I fell I could seriously get hurt and I said you know you can't play hockey like that you can't play any sport like that right and I just said you know what I don't want to
但我过去经常参加很多，我猜是慈善活动、慈善比赛，人们会说，嘿，韦恩，加入进来吧，我说，行，我打几个换人轮次，有一次我回到家，大约是七年前，我大约54岁，我放下包，转身对珍妮特说，你知道吗，这是我最后一次滑冰了，她问你在说什么，我说，这是我生命中第一次在冰上感到害怕，如果我摔倒了，我可能会严重受伤，我说，你知道，你不能那样打曲棍球，你不能那样打任何运动，对吧，我只是说，你知道吗，我不想
push it I've had a good run I love the game everything I have in my life is because of hockey I don't need to be breaking my leg because I think I can still play what was your what was your secret to what seems to my eyes you seem like such a happy peaceful content guy what was your secret to the successful transition from being exposed to an opportunity day in and day out for so many years to excel and dominate when it when it stopped I'm sure you knew there was no way to be able to replace that what did you did you just lay some groundwork so that that was a smooth transition into what is seems to me a
强求了，我度过了一段美好的时光，我热爱这项运动，我生命中的一切都是因为曲棍球，我不需要因为我觉得自己还能打而把腿摔断，对于我眼中的你，你似乎是一个如此快乐、平静、满足的人，你从长年累月身处机会之中、不断脱颖而出并占据统治地位，到当这一切停止时实现成功过渡的秘诀是什么？我敢肯定你知道根本无法替代那种感觉，你是如何为平稳过渡到如今在我看来非常满足的生活打下基础的呢？还是说存在一个让人感到不舒服的适应过程？
very content life that you're living now or was there was there an adjustment that was uncomfortable no there's an adjustment I think that any athlete who said there was no adjustment is lying because you know you have this passion and love and it's like going to school you know I I can remember we used to start school the day after Labor Day and we knew we're in school all year till early June and that's when we got out hockey was the same thing I knew I was going to training camp the day after Labor Day yeah and I was at their mercy every single day of practice or travel or games and I did that all year
不，确实有一个适应过程，我认为任何说没有适应过程的运动员都是在撒谎，因为你知道，你有这种激情和爱，这就像上学一样，你知道的，我记得我们过去常常在劳动节的第二天开始上学，我们知道我们一整年都在上学，直到6月初，那才是我们放假的时候，曲棍球也是一样的，我知道我会在劳动节的第二天去训练营，是的，每天的训练、旅行或比赛，我都听凭他们的摆布，我一整年都这样做
and then you get your six or eight weeks off in the summer time to be with friends and family and I would say this all the time to people if you're gonna be a good athlete in any sport you have to be extremely selfish and I mean that in the most positive way selfish I mean the night before a game deep properly to get your proper rest the day of a game to focus and get ready and the people around you your family your wife your kids your friends your parents they all have to be on that same page and I was lucky they were all on that page they understood when I was playing that was my life yeah they set you up for success
然后你在夏天有六到八周的假期，和朋友家人在一起，我总是对人们说，如果你想成为任何运动中的优秀运动员，你必须极其自私，我是在最积极的意义上这么说的，自私，我的意思是比赛前一晚要好好休息以获得充足的休息，比赛当天要专注于做好准备，你周围的人，你的家人、你的妻子、你的孩子、你的朋友、你的父母，他们都必须在同一页上，我很幸运，他们都在同一页上，他们明白当我打球时，那就是我的生活，是的，他们为你走向成功做好了准备
yeah and then and then when I was done you know I was lucky I had a great family my kids are wonderful there's new challenges right there's new things on the horizon but I say this all the time nothing's gonna ever replace that high that I got being a hockey player and that's why you still see guys who are 45 or 55 they play pick-up hockey on Sundays they still think back to their childhood right yeah this was so much fun I don't want to give it up I want to still keep playing even though they can't play even though they're not very good anymore but they're still out there because the game itself is like it's like
对，然后，然后当我结束的时候，你知道，我很幸运，我有一个伟大的家庭，我的孩子很棒，有新的挑战，对吧，地平线上有新的事物，但我总是说这句话，没有什么能取代那种作为曲棍球运动员获得的亢奋感，这就是为什么你仍然会看到45岁或55岁的家伙，他们在周日打野球，他们仍然会回想起他们的童年，对吧，是的，这太有趣了，我不想放弃它，我仍然想继续打球，尽管他们不能打了，尽管他们已经不再擅长了，但他们仍然在场上，因为这项运动本身就像
a drug it just pulls you in if you have that passion for it there's nothing like it I had that thing Wayne you know for your I haven't been back to Toronto at Christmas in a few years now but I would go back and play shinny with the guys I grew up with and I could go down to the rink like Ramston Park in Toronto right right across from Roseville subway station right off Young Street and I could go and see the same guys who play shinny there like on a Sunday or in the afternoons that I've played my whole life with and I can tell you something and as a guy who did not play at a high level at all the feeling I'd get from
一种毒品，如果你对它有那种激情，它就会把你拉进去，没有什么能与之相比，我有过那种感觉，韦恩，你知道的，我已经有好几年没在圣诞节回多伦多去了，但我会回去和跟我一起长大的伙伴们一起打街头冰球，我可以去多伦多的冰场，比如拉姆斯登公园，就在罗丝代尔地铁站对面，就在央街旁边，我可以去见那些和我一起打了一辈子街头冰球的伙伴们，比如在周日或下午，我可以告诉你一件事，作为一个根本没有达到高水平的家伙，那种感觉
walking from my car to that little dressing room that's run by the you know parks department of Toronto to put my skates on I couldn't do it fast enough I can't get out there fast enough because I love the game so much that that I I can access that memory now which is but I wanted to get into this thing which is and tell Sean and Jason one of my favorite stories I mean I have so many favorite stories about you that I've heard that are part of the legend but one is there's a there's a record in hockey guys that was that rocket Richard first broke which was 50 goals in 50 games which it was almost unheard
从我的车走到多伦多公园部门管理的那个小更衣室去穿上冰鞋，我都恨不得动作快点再快点，我迫不及待地想上冰场，因为我太热爱这项运动了，以至于我可以唤醒那段记忆，但这太棒了，但我想要进入这个话题，告诉肖恩和杰森我最喜欢的故事之一，我的意思是关于你的故事我听过太多我最喜欢的了，它们都是传奇的一部分，其中一个是，曲棍球界有一个纪录，伙计们，火箭理查德率先打破了这个纪录，那就是在50场比赛中攻入50球，这简直是闻所未闻
of so he did that he sets the mark Wayne had of and correct me if I'm wrong way but you had 45 goals in 38 games leading up to a game right so he had 45 so he had to get five more goals but he only played in 38 games and your roommate at the time was Kevin Lowe the great Kevin Lowe he was your teammate and Wayne says to him on this day he says to he goes and Kevin Lowe tells the story I'm gonna get five goals tonight and he called the shot and he went out and Wayne scored five goals to score 50 goals in 39 yeah it wasn't from bragging it was more a sense of if I get this close and don't do it I'm gonna
所以他做到了，他设定了目标，韦恩曾——如果我错了请纠正我，韦恩——在进入一场比赛前，你在38场比赛中进了45个球，对吧？所以他有45个，所以他还需要再进5个球，但他只打了38场比赛，你当时的室友是凯文·洛，伟大的凯文·洛，他是你的队友，韦恩在那天对他说了——他告诉凯文·洛说——凯文·洛讲了这个故事：我今晚要进5个球。他下了战书，然后上场韦恩进了5个球，在39场比赛中进了50个球，对，那不是吹牛，这更像是一种感觉：如果我离这个目标这么近却没有做到，我会被
be known as a slug so I felt more pressure to get to that 50 as fast as I could and it just happened that night I got five so I was pretty excited it just happened how did that feel though what was that feeling knowing that you did that poor goal tender you know it I don't know it was special you unique I felt honored all that goes with that right I look back at it now I was a kid just having fun right I didn't know any better I was 22 years old just doing what I love doing and you just go play right what do you what do you think Wayne is like the the physics behind something you understand and you get
叫做笨蛋，所以我感到了更大的压力，要尽我所能尽快达到50个，刚好那天我进了5个，所以我非常兴奋，事情就这样发生了。不过当时感觉如何？你知道，那种知道自己做到了的感觉，对那个可怜的门将而言，你知道，我不知道，这很特别、很独特，我感到很荣幸，所有这些都随之而来，对吧？我如今回想起来，我当时只是个觉得好玩的小孩，对吧？我什么都不懂，我22岁，只是在做我热爱的事，然后你就去打球，对吧？你认为——你认为韦恩是怎么样的？那种你理解并掌握的物理机制，你比其他球员理解得更多
you understand more than other players like for example that that example I went into this game I scored 50 games in our 50 points and how many games what is it you do you don't have to brag or it's not egotistical but just technically speaking what is it you do that what is it you have that you don't think other people do you know that Wayne before you answer that to set you up a little bit more Sean to kind of like in addition to that I remember asking a few people what it was like playing against Wayne and they would say you had a sense for the game we always talked about Wayne you you had a sense for it because I want to
比如那个例子，我进入这场比赛，我在多少场比赛中得到了50场比赛中的50分？这是怎么回事？你不需要吹牛，这也不是自大，但仅从技术层面来说，你做了什么？你有什么别人没有的东西？你知道的，韦恩，在你回答之前，为了多铺垫一点，肖恩，有点像除此之外，我还记得问过一些人，和韦恩对抗是什么感觉，他们会说，你对比赛有一种直觉，我们总是谈论韦恩，你对它有一种直觉，因为我想
know about this because they'd say all of a sudden the play would be over here and Wayne would be over there and all of a sudden the play would end up over there so you did you feel like you always had a sense for how the plays were gonna unfold I don't know you know yeah like what is that sixth sense like how it's like it's almost like a quarterback in football like how do they have that you know the great ones how do they have that ability he is the great ones yeah you know I think a couple things first of all I had a tremendous amount of respect for my opponents I always played each and every guy like they were
知道这个，因为他们会说，突然之间比赛就在这边，韦恩就在那边，然后突然之间比赛就会结束在那边，所以你觉得你总是对比赛将如何展开有一种直觉吗？我不知道，你知道的，是的，就像那种第六感是什么？就像橄榄球里的四分卫一样，那些伟大的球员怎么会有这种能力？是的，那些伟大的球员，你知道的，我认为有几件事，首先，我对我的对手有极大的尊重，我总是把每一个家伙都当成是
better than I was and that I had to be at my best to be able to play well the game itself I when I started talking to you guys earlier when I made that team at six years old with 10 year olds then at 14 I played with 20 year olds and at 17 I played with men yeah and the one thing I didn't ever have to do I was never big I was always the smallest guy I was always on the smaller side I wasn't physically strong I wasn't the fastest so my dad always taught me at a young age you better be smart out there you better play chess you better be one step ahead because that's how you're gonna angle to be as good or better than
比我强，我必须拿出最佳状态才能打好比赛。比赛本身，当我刚才开始和你们谈话时，当我6岁时加入了那个有10岁孩子的球队，然后在14岁时我和20岁的人一起打球，在17岁时我和成年人一起打球，是的，我从来不需要做的一件事是，我从来都不是身材高大的，我总是最小的家伙，我总是偏瘦小的那一边，我在身体上并不强壮，我也不是速度最快的，所以我爸爸从小就教导我，你在场上最好聪明点，你最好玩国际象棋，你最好领先一步，因为那是你如何通过角度来变得和他们一样好甚至更好
they are and so I never had to change my game from the time I was six years old so when I retired at 39 I still mentally focused and tried to play the same way so I would say it was my hockey sense my sixth sense on the ice that was the difference in my skill level compared to maybe some other guys it's just interesting how some people are some athletes like yourself are just honed in than others you know Sean has that in the kitchen he'll be he'll be like he'll be like I know that there's some checks mix in that cupboard and he opens it and then there it is filled with checks it's kind of amazing yeah he makes with
的方式。所以我从6岁起就再也没有改变过我的打法，所以当我39岁退役时，我依然保持着精神上的专注，并试图用同样的方式打球。所以我想说的是，是我的冰球直觉，我在冰面上的第六感，这造就了我和其他一些球员相比在技能水平上的差异。有趣的是，有些人，一些像你这样的运动员，就是比其他人更敏锐，你知道的，肖恩在厨房里就是这样，他会说，我知道那个碗柜里有一些夹心脆饼，然后他一打开，里面就全是夹心脆饼，这真是太神奇了，是的，他用
bugles and he's got a sense so now you know first of all you know Wayne of course you Wayne is known as the great one in which I can't imagine there ever being a better nickname to be given to a guy ever of all time but now you have this this new company this clothing company greatness wins and I see you have a t-shirt on yeah I was wondering what that was talks me a little bit about about how this partnership came about and what it's all about well I think we got lucky in a sense that Derek Jeter who was running the Florida Marlins decided to take a step back and say you know what I was helpful in building this
长笛脆饼（Bugles），他有一种直觉。所以现在你知道了，首先，你知道，韦恩，当然，韦恩被称为“伟大的人”（The Great One），我无法想象历史上还会有比这更好的昵称给一个人了，但现在你有了这个新公司，这个服装公司“伟大的胜利”（Greatness Wins），我看到你穿着一件T恤，是的，我想知道那是什么，跟我多讲讲这个合作是怎么开始的，以及它是关于什么的。嗯，我想我们在某种程度上很幸运，曾执掌佛罗里达马林鱼队的德里克·杰特决定退一步说，你知道吗，我在建设
Nike shoe line when he was building baseball cleats in the mid 90s and he just kind of dove all in and said you know I really excited about this company that you know I want to be part of something that starts from the ground floor and called me and asked me if I wanted to jump on board with him and of course anytime Derek Jeter calls you you take that phone call and say okay I'm definitely in and as I always tell people nobody told me how to play hockey I'm not gonna tell them how to make a peril but I'm really excited about it they're great guys they're wonderful and I'm it's an honor for me to be part of
耐克鞋履产品线时曾发挥过作用，当时他在90年代中期打造棒球钉鞋，他直接全身心投入说，我真的对这家公司感到兴奋，你知道的，我想成为从零开始的事业的一部分，他打电话问我是否想和他一起加入，当然，每当德里克·杰特打电话给你，你都会接那个电话，说“好的，我绝对加入”。正如我总是告诉人们的那样，没有人告诉我怎么打冰球，我也不会告诉他们怎么做服装，但我真的对此感到兴奋，他们都是很棒的人，他们太棒了，对我来说，能够成为
it and plus I got a free t-shirt today yeah and thank you for sending us all that stuff Jason loves getting free stuff I don't know if you heard him talking about the thing we all we all like free stuff it's free it's for me and I'll take all three can people get can people get it now is it up and running now yeah it's online yeah yeah golf shirts it's just nice apparel so we're really excited let's go Jason golf you know you'd mention Gordy how and I heard the great story recently from a mutual friend of mine and Jason's and I don't know wait if you know us the great skip Bronson hilarious dude and skip
其中一部分是一种荣幸，而且我今天还得到了一件免费的T恤，是的，谢谢你给我们寄的所有东西，杰森很喜欢拿免费的东西，我不知道你有没有听见他谈论那件事，我们都——我们都喜欢免费的东西，它是免费的，是给我的，我全都要。人们现在能买到吗？现在在运营吗？是的，在线上，对，对，高尔夫球衫，这只是漂亮的服装，所以我们真的很兴奋。我们走吧，杰森，高尔夫。你知道，你提到了戈迪·豪，我最近从我和杰森的共同朋友那里听到了一个很棒的故事，我不知道韦恩你认不认识，伟大的斯kip·布朗森（Skip Bronson），一个搞笑的家伙，斯kip
told me a story when he was involved way back in the day with the Hartford Whalers he says to Gordy he says Sean by the way Gordy how is one of the all-time great hockey players it wanes idle and a lot of many many people's idle and he was a tremendous he says he said the skip says to me says Gordy how did you never how are you still playing in your fifth he played into his 50s because he played with his sons right 51 51 he says how did you play so so long he said I never picked anything up and he goes what do you mean he goes I never picked up a package an envelope if anything came in I'd say knowing good because I
告诉我一个故事，当他很久以前在哈特福德捕鲸者队（Hartford Whalers）工作时，他对戈迪说——他说，肖恩，顺便说一句，戈迪·豪是历史上最伟大的冰球运动员之一，是韦恩的偶像，也是许许多多人的偶像，他非常——斯kip对我说，他说，戈迪·豪，你怎么从来——你怎么还能在50多岁的时候还在打球？因为他是和他的儿子们一起打球的，对吧？51、51岁，他说，你怎么能打这么久？他说，我从来不捡起任何东西。他说，你是什么意思？他说，我从来不捡起任何包裹或信封，如果有任何东西寄来，我会说“没门，好极了”，因为我
always knew that that's how people injured themselves Gordy Gordy was so wonderful I'll give you a great story we went to the White House in 1980 for the NHL All-Star game and Gordy and I were fortunate enough we sat at the same table as President Reagan and I was a kid I was 18 years old I was sweating I had a three-piece suit on it's probably too tight and I was sitting there and I turned to Gordy there was like six forks and seven knives and I go Gordy what what fork do we use he goes I'll tell you what I'll watch him you watch me and so Gordy was President Reagan and then so that night we got home and my dad says to
一直都知道那是人们受伤的方式。戈迪，戈迪太棒了，我给你们讲个很棒的故事，我们在1980年去白宫参加NHL全明星赛，戈迪和我非常幸运，我们和里根总统坐在同一张桌子旁。我当时是个孩子，我才18岁，我在冒汗，我穿着一件三件套西装，可能太紧了，我坐在那里，我转向戈迪，那里大约有六把叉子和七把刀，我问：“戈迪，我们该用哪把叉子？”他说：“这样吧，我看着他，你看着我。”所以戈迪就是里根总统，然后那天晚上我们回到家，我爸爸问
me how is it having lunch at the White House and I said I'll tell you how great Gordy how is and he said how is that and I said I heard the president of the United States turn to Gordy how and say you know what Gordy I don't trust those F and Russians I said I heard the president swear that's how cool Gordy how is yeah that's how cool Gordy is let's go man Wayne listen you played a lot of games you played who who is the toughest goalie you ever played I've always wanted to know that in your I mean I'm Billy Smith Billy Smith hey yeah he was because they're all so good there's such great
我：“在白宫吃午餐感觉怎么样？”我说：“我告诉你戈迪·豪有多伟大吧。”他说：“怎么个伟大发说法？”我说：“我听到美国总统转过身对戈迪·豪说，‘你知道吗，戈迪，我不信任那些该死的俄罗斯人。’我说我听到总统骂粗口了，戈迪·豪就是这么酷。”是的，戈迪就是这么酷。我们走吧，兄弟。韦恩，听着，你打了很多场比赛，你打过——谁是你交手过的最强硬的门将？我一直想知道这个，在你的职业生涯中——我是说比利·史密斯（Billy Smith），比利·史密斯，嘿，是的，因为他们都太优秀了，他们是如此出色的
athletes and they're better athletes today than we were 40 years ago but Billy Smith the game on the line pressure and the thing that made him so good is he hated me and I hated him but that was when we played right and now that we're done and over we have a mutual respect for each other and he was no question one of the greatest ever did you ever roll one off his back that was one of my favorite moves that that you did you know listener he'd get behind the net and the goalie would have his back to him and he'd flip it up over the net and roll it off the back of goalie's back in the net no he was too good and
运动员，而且他们比我们40年前的运动员更出色，但比利·史密斯，在比赛胜负攸关、压力巨大的时刻，而让他如此优秀的原因是他讨厌我，我也讨厌他，但那是我们还在比赛的时候，现在我们退役了，结束了，我们对彼此有着共同的尊重，他毫无疑问是有史以来最伟大的球员之一。你有没有在他后背上滑过球？那是我最喜欢的你的绝招之一，你知道的，听众朋友，他会绕到球门后面，门将背对著他，他会把球挑过球门，从门将的后背上滑进球门。不，他太优秀了，也
too smart for that people don't do that anymore right if I was back there he'd be swinging his stick at me so he was a great great goalie for the for the New York Islanders and when Wayne played with Edmonton and they had been the dominant dynasty before Wayne and the and the Oilers came in and took over took the fought the mantle off right from those guys what epic hockey Wayne you just I don't know you just you made so many people's day over the years you've been such an incredible ambassador for the sport of hockey and you've done so much and it's such a thrill to have you honestly I just great to meet I could
太聪明了，人们现在不那样做了，对吧？如果我在那后面，他会拿着棍子挥向我。所以他是纽约岛人队（New York Islanders）一位伟大、伟大的门将。当韦恩效力于埃德蒙顿，并且在韦恩和油人队到来并接管、从这些人手中夺走权杖之前，他们一直是占据统治地位的王朝，对吧？多么史诗般的冰球啊，韦恩，你只是——我不知道，这些年来你让那么多人的生活大放异彩，你一直是冰球运动如此不可思议的大使，你做了那么多，能拥有你真是太激动了，老实说，很高兴认识你，我能
talk to you all day I love I love every time I really respect all three you guys and you got a great show even there's talking about it on NBC from what I heard earlier let's go play some golf and we'll finish up this conversation all right you guys listen I loved Ed and we'll keep keep promoting our game you do a great job for the game of hockey thanks guys thanks Wayne we'll talk to you soon pleasure thanks buddy bye oh and he slams a laptop it's only the great one knows the great stuff yeah yeah I know I don't know like it was really cool first of all I said I know who he is and of course look at this I
跟你聊上一整天，我喜欢——我喜欢每一次，我真的非常尊重你们三个人，你们有一个很棒的节目，正如我早些时候在NBC上听到别人谈论的那样。我们去打几杆高尔夫球吧，然后我们就结束这次谈话。好吧，伙计们，听着，我爱你们，我们会继续推广我们的运动，你们为冰球运动做得很好。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你，韦恩，我们过会儿聊。荣幸之至，谢谢你，兄弟，再见。哦，他猛地合上了笔记本电脑，只有“伟大的人”才知道这些好东西，对，对，我知道，我不知道，就像这真的太酷了，首先我说我知道他是谁，当然看看这个，我
don't know what's that we got chills yeah I got chills wait were you freaking out well because you're that is that like an eye because he closed the laptop or because he told you you're you're doing great for the hockey just anything he says to me and every time he remembers my name I I know I'm like I'm just gonna end it now isn't that crazy you guys like I'm sorry yeah I know the three of us have been in this business a long time we've met a lot of fancy people but it is it will never be lost on me how fortunate we are and it's thanks to you listener that we have this this opportunity this platform to like talk
不知道，那是什么？我们起鸡皮疙瘩了，是的，我起鸡皮疙瘩了。韦恩，你刚才吓坏了吗？因为你——是因为他合上了笔记本电脑，还是因为他跟你说你们为冰球运动做得很好？只要是他对我说的话，以及他每次都能记住我的名字，我知道，我就想“我现在就把它结束算了”。这难道不疯狂吗，伙计们？就像，我很抱歉，是的，我知道我们三个在这个行业里很久了，我们见过很多大人物，但我永远不会忘记我们是多么幸运，正是因为有你们听众，我们才有这样的机会、这个平台去
to these people that are huge heroes to us and we get to just speak like on a peer level and like shoot the shit with them it's just I know I know Jason Jason I really think that people are able to get how much we do respect that position that we have by the fact that every time that your mouth is full of food that really sells that really sells how appreciative you are the finest protein bars made the name is think so wait you know it's so great about Wayne that like he's first of all not only a great hockey player but a great storyteller like like you could say I had a BLT and he'd be like oh my god I have the greatest
和这些人对话——这些人是我们的超级英雄，我们能够以平等的姿态与他们对话，和他们闲聊。这真是，我知道，我知道，杰森，杰森，我真的认为人们能够理解我们对这个职位的尊重有多深，通过这样一个事实：每次你满嘴都是食物时，这真的证明了这一点，这真的证明了你是多么感激。最棒的蛋白棒，名字叫Think。所以，你知道韦恩最棒的地方是什么吗？他不仅是个伟大的冰球运动员，还是个伟大的故事大王——就像你可以说“我吃了一个BLT三明治”，而他会说“天哪，我有一个关于BLT的最棒的
story about a BLT and it's and it's enthralling it's like I was listening to every single word like wow yeah yeah he does he has such a knowledge and I meant that he is such a I've seen him in so many different scenarios I've seen him in you know the first time I met him I was on a plane to Toronto and Archie was about I don't know five or six or something and we were flying up there just the two of us and Wayne what gets on last to get on the plane and and he's like two rows in front of us Wayne comes back and he says he comes over to me he's Wayne Gretzky and I'm too nervous to say anything and we're flying up
故事”，而且它太迷人了，就像我在听每一个字一样，哇，是的，是的，他确实拥有这样的知识，我是说真的，他就是一个——我曾在许多不同的场景中见过他，我第一次见他时，我正坐去多伦多的飞机上，阿尔奇（Archie）大约五、六岁左右，我们俩飞上去，而韦恩是最后一个上飞机的人，他坐在我们前面两排，韦恩走过来，他说——他向我走来，他是韦恩·格雷茨基，而我太紧张了，什么也说不出来，我们正飞往
right I mean he's Canadian royalty and and he says hey will bubble I said hey this is my nice to meet you hey this is my son Archie Archie how you doing blah blah blah and then he's got his boarding pass and he writes his phone number he goes give me a call I'm going to Toronto but give me a call and let's hang out blah blah blah I go no problem and I gotta turn to my turn to my five or six-year-old and be like I just got Wayne Gretzky's phone number yeah that's so cool and I and anyway I've now subsequently met him you know a bunch of times over the years and he's always such a and he never never deviates from
那里，对吧，我的意思是他是加拿大皇室成员，他说：“嘿，威尔，宝贝。”我说：“嘿，这是我的——很高兴见到你，嘿，这是我的儿子阿尔奇，阿尔奇，你好吗，巴拉巴拉。”然后他拿着登机牌，写下他的电话号码，他说：“给我打电话，我要去多伦多，但给我打电话，我们一起出去玩，巴拉巴拉。”我说：“没问题。”然后我转过身对我的五六岁的孩子说：“我刚刚得到了韦恩·格雷茨基的电话号码。”是的，这太酷了。而且无论如何，这些年来我后来又多次见到他，他总是那么——他从来没有偏离过
that and he's and he talks to everybody and he's such a sweet kind open generous guy to quote Jason generous with his time and you know there's something about him that is just I don't know I just his ability was always so clear I mean you know you could even if you had the worst seat in the house you could see how good he is you you would not need by smart smart list is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco Michael Grant Terry and Rob I'm Jeff smart loss our next episode will be
这一点，他跟每个人都说话，他是一个如此甜美、善良、开放、慷慨的人——引用杰森的话，“对他的时间很慷慨”——你知道，他身上有一种特质，我不知道，我只是——他的能力总是那么清晰，我的意思是，你知道，即使你买的是全场最烂的座位，你也能看出他有多优秀，你根本不需要——SmartLess由本尼迪克特·巴尔巴科、迈克尔·格兰特、特里和罗布100%有机且手工制作。我是杰夫·斯马特利斯。我们的下一期节目将在
out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondry app There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
一周后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐（Amazon Music）上抢先收听，或者通过在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）或Wondry应用上订阅Wondry Plus来抢先收听并免广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。